five
four three two
hello and welcome to the first ever
frenemies
live i am your host eden klein with me
of course
is trisha payton the other host a friend
of mine the other
with the most yeah you yeah
um what are we doing here today why are
we here
we did an emergency frenemies live
episode because
i just punched the mic hopefully
people's ears didn't just explode
um jeff whittick who is another vlog
squad member
made a response video it's kind of how
would you
how would you rate this next to scotty's
response video
they're pretty they're pretty equal i
would say i would say this might be
scotty might be like a three in korean
just might be like a one on a scale of
one to ten one being like
so you think jeff's is worse than scotty
i think it's a lot worse
yeah so at least scotty like and
scotty's he's like hey guys
you know i'm a i'm a dumbass
but jeff's is a little worse in my
opinion because what he does that really
fired me up and made me want to go live
is because he first of all blames you
and the author
for putting him in this situation
and i feel the people he should really
be mad with are his friends
like david who put him and then and and
like todd who it seems todd is the one
that bought the alcohol who's letting
jeff take the fall
yeah he was mad at me because he says
trish is the one that brings us up i'm
like i've always shared my story i've
shared this story before and it's like
other people have come forward like i'm
not
i'm not the one bringing this up i'm not
the one trying to like come for him
which he thinks and
i don't know i just was like yeah i was
i was really upset that it like because
it's easy to put it on me but it's not
about me which is like really annoying
and he texted me
like we had a phone call last week he
texted me this morning and he like i
just felt like he didn't get it
so when he was like i'll call in i
thought you know
i don't know i don't i don't think he
gets it so that's why i was like well
maybe it makes sense to do this with you
i feel like you're a little more
maybe un attached to this than i am i
don't know a little more removed from it
but i just like i don't think he gets it
or maybe well to be frank with you i
don't think he read the article
based on his response video i really
genuinely don't
there's really no other way to explain
some of the things he says
right because he said i'm the only one
saying that they left to go get the
alcohol when
in fact that's not true he's clearly
been accused by the sober friends
several of the witnesses there that
night who spoke to insiders saying him
and todd returned with alcohol
that whatever whatever we're going to
watch his response video
okay and then he's going to call in
to give his side of the story does also
kind of skip around the part of like
what happened after he's so focused on
like well maybe trisha brought that you
know that kind of stuff where it's like
it's kind of also more of like the fact
that he stuck around
oh yeah that participated yeah like
you're
i don't know who bought the alcohol have
that tweet should i pull it out i was
like
he goes i don't know who bought the
alcohol maybe it was trisha that bought
the alcohol
that's literally nobody said that except
for you and also like
yeah i just i don't know i just here
here's the tweet we're referring to
so i'm sure this is going to come up can
they see this dan
okay oh yeah he says he says maybe dom
bought it maybe you bought it maybe one
of the underage girls bought it
i'm just saying it definitely wasn't me
or todd nobody told me [ __ ] i thought it
was a consensual bit sorry i didn't say
hi at starbucks that one time
of course insinuating that you're trying
to ruin his life because he didn't say
how to use starbucks
which isn't even the case with starbucks
incident not that it matters
don't you he literally said i'll tell
you what if i see you in starbucks i'm
definitely saying hi
i don't want you to [ __ ] my life up over
something like that jaffa is like
if you see christian starbucks you best
say [ __ ] hi
he ran out without his coffee they
called jeff and i saw him run out in the
mirror and he just like ran out on the
back he didn't get his coffee so he's
just a coward because like basically
they are all scared to say his name i
mean it is funny that he saw you and
just
it's funny that's why i said it what did
he leave behind how much food did he do
it was a coffee and a sandwich and he
just left it he just left it
because they called his name later and
he wasn't there to get it no i'm behind
him he sees me he's already ordered he's
in the back i can see in the reflection
of the window him like
moving back out and then they call jeff
so i look back because he's not getting
it and i was just like oh he's not even
here so i saw him leave and i was like
oh he literally just left his coffee
we got to talk about that because that
seems i want to get to the actual truth
of what happened with the starbucks
incident
because then he tried to go on on his
podcast saying like i don't respect her
i'm like no you were scared like if you
didn't respect
it it was not like i said hi to him i
wasn't going to sign him either i was
like oh yeah you can just you don't have
to
go out you know like it's not you could
you know what i mean
anyways but anyway so he's going to call
in after
we look over this sheriff like i know
people will say it's not a big deal but
it is like he is also he's older than me
so at the time he was like 30
and these girls are you know 20 year old
fan girls of david like he should know
better in the situation i knew better i
was like this is not a situation to be
in like we should probably like
leave and right and i will i'll he
says he'll stand on like you know take
it to the grave whatever mine too i
stand by it that david did ask jeff
after and todd and jeff said i'll get it
whether he got or not i wasn't there and
i said that to him i wasn't there for
that
that girl who was there claims it and we
don't i don't know that girl we've never
talked i didn't know it before the
article
i actually just found it this morning to
see if she said i'm like no i swear
someone else had it and i saw it so
that was mine i don't know well there's
a there's a um
i want to watch this video but kat had a
lot of interesting receipts the author
who he called out a lot
but regarding who got the alcohol if i
play listen to this
i don't see how that is
all like you know yeah
exactly so he tried to he tried to slam
dunk on cap by being like i've got all
these receipts so cat's like okay well
i recorded the conversation too dude so
here he is saying
listen closely
sure [ __ ] sounds like it to me oh
like you know
right and he also keeps saying if people
don't speak then they're guilty and
that's why he's speaking it's like todd
hasn't spoken
jason's like you know you should be mad
at your todd and [ __ ] david for
letting you take the brunt of [ __ ] like
the fact that you're
you're you're anyway we should watch it
because maybe a lot of sponsors and todd
doesn't do anything so he's not losing
[ __ ]
but at the same time can i say i've
never had a vendetta like i don't not
even offended against anyone but i've
never had even
a beef with jeff like the fact that he
thinks i've never had an issue of all
the people in the group i've called them
out
todd brandon calvillo david and jason
those are the four people
i didn't know dom like this at all
obviously at the time but like obviously
i will group him on that too but the
four people i've continuously called out
are those people and never once was it
jeff
because i don't think jeff is as creepy
as those other guys i think it was a
poor choice for him to partake in this
bit and he should
you know get the repercussions of it
because it's gross and that's why we
left i was like this is not going to be
good like you're 30 you should know this
but i also think at the same time like
he's not as creepy as todd brandon david
and jason so i'm gonna say that for the
record like i don't think james is
definitely worse
and my initial reaction to his
involvement was like
i get that he's in this unfortunate
situation
and if he just lays his [ __ ] head low
and just minds his own
like he's not the main perpetrator here
you know what i told him because we had
a co we had about an hour phone call on
last tuesday and i said to him i said
you know and he apologized but you
didn't apologize for me i kept telling
him like why are you apologizing to me i
said it's more just like own up rather
than like deflecting on me saying trish
is crazy all stuff or just [ __ ] on
top whatever
just own up to like i was that was a
shitty situation like i'm so [ __ ]
embarrassed to be a part of it
but like nobody can like just own up to
even david himself right they can't just
say like
[ __ ] that was so cool you know would
have been the best if he just said
i regret being involved i should have
known better i should have never been
there
that i i was totally unacceptable i'm
just you know what i'm ashamed i
shouldn't have been
yeah that's it but like so now so anyway
the reason that i felt compelled to do
this on short notes of juice live
is because i saw him he literally puts
the reporters twitter
and his video and says she should be
fired and is
indirectly encouraging his audience to
go
like harass her because he said she
printed lies which that
witness gave her that big i don't think
he even read the article so now i'm
saying we need we actually need to
correct the record here because this is
not right what he's done in his video
so that's why we're here i'm going to
watch we're going to watch videos
in that response video is like so
different than the jeff i talked to on
tuesday like again i don't know jeff i
do not know him like this at all but
like
he was so different in that video where
he seemed actually remorseful and like
scared and like like oh my god like i
can't believe i did this [ __ ] as opposed
to the video
or he's trying to like go on me go on
her and i'm just like like
he's so worried about losing his
sponsors and the whole thing and it's
like this girl got like you know
there's like a serious thing terrible
yeah i think losing a sponsor is like
okay
in this situation like that's the least
you could you know he feels like i
didn't do anything why is this happening
but you did you participate in that you
just
you got yeah i mean look nobody's nobody
was
really literally directly blaming you
you could
you listen dude you [ __ ] up with this
video bro
it's like you were there it's like just
take accountability of it like
because i think what he's doing he's
trying to still protect his friends
and that's what's getting him in trouble
everyone's just doing this old boys club
where nobody wants to say anything
i said you need to stop protecting
protecting todd and david because they
are problematic and they're
there was one did you get the tweet
about todd saying like you know he
encouraged someone to gang bang his
ex-girlfriend corinna he's like yeah as
many people
it was on i think it's on cat's twitter
today and someone's like oh how
like how many guys would you like to
have sex with kroonen's like they can
all gangbang your volunteer like it's
like a repeated
todd so he has like a repeated way he
was dating karen and he wanted dudes
after he was dating her like someone's
like well anyways there's a repeated
behavior jeff included there's
jeff went on to tell say that people
with mental illness should have a social
media platform like there's like
repeated behavior of these people that
are really like
nasty and gross and it's like hey like
maybe you've grown from it but like take
some
when he talked to me he said he was
going through some serious [ __ ] and he
can obviously he'll be on later maybe
he'll say it and i was like okay so in
this case it's time for you to reflect
he's like i can understand why you would
have a breakdown because he was there at
the hospital
and he's like oh at first i just thought
like you were on drugs and [ __ ] and
crazy and he's like now i understand
where you're coming from and i was like
okay well then if you have some sort of
compassion like at least have compassion
for this girl and
and just know that you were there like
oh you know that reminds me of the other
clip that
there's so many new clips that came out
about david the david situation
honestly of girls who saying they were
in a similar situation where they were
being given alcohol
and they were underage and the other
there's like dude going to go there's
like 20 viral videos
but there was there was one really
interesting one
let me see if i've got it here where
it's a lot of everything you've said is
being
like continually corroborated for
example you told a story about how
um david kept trying to push you guys to
be in a threesome you and jason
and you started taking off your clothes
because you didn't want him to use the
footing
yeah and he continued and well the video
surfaced do you it's oh
you've you're highlighting it thank you
so much i got it right here
this is is this it just called actually
if you wanted to
did you ever and so he keeps going on
and on about how consent is so important
to him
here you are you're you're so far from
consenting
yeah you're taking off a close in an
effort to make the footage
unusable yeah i said this so many times
and i think that
he blurs it and then posts it to make
you look like you're crazy
of course yeah tana just called actually
she wanted it
yeah i take my clothes off i take my
clothes off in this bit like i [ __ ]
go i lose my shirt
put your
because i didn't want him to use it in
the in the vlog i'm like if i get
completely naked he can't use it you'll
see he like leaves it in and like blurs
it out her dress is literally off she's
laughing
literally like he has no he doesn't
he has no boundary no and he stopped
using it for sick like for
about three months after that he never
just said the tina thing and i got
brought up that week
that final week before i like did my
video on him or whatever but yeah he
stopped after that because i kept saying
don't use it it's not funny
um but there's so much here though it's
like just girl after girl after girl at
this point
but literally everything you've ever
said has been totally corroborated
everything and they have worked overtime
to just characterize you as some crazy
girl
who just has who's just out for revenge
but every single footage and everything
that's come out has
vin has 100 supported everything you say
that these guys are dangerous
that they're flirting with disaster
they're putting people in dangerous
situations
and more and more it shows that your
concerns are genuine
but and well-founded when i made that
video like everyone has this like
preconceived thing that like i was
already dumped and jason already broke
up with me so i was like this
ex-girlfriend that was bitter it's like
no like me and jason shot a music video
the day before i made that video like we
were
but then when they put that bit in again
with tana and i think madison beer when
they were like 18 years old and jason's
back they're being creepy then i was
like you know what and i and i reached
out to david and jason
and jason said um i remember him telling
me like i'm going to sleep and block it
like i'm blocking like
oh he didn't say i'm blocking you like
i'm going to talk to you later about
this and this is 7am i text david he's
on a plane to chicago he's like oh now
he said it was okay so like [ __ ] off
basically is how he said it so that's
why i made the videos like fine nobody
wants to talk to me about this like i'll
make a video and i had all my
but i had brought up brandon before i
had brought up todd's behavior before
and all of them were totally fine with
like other things in the group
and yeah it is it's so easily proven
just like the brandon thing being dating
a 17 year old like that was proven like
i'm not saying [ __ ] that's like
untrue why would i leave i loved being
in that relationship with jason like i
knew making that video i would be out of
it but like i did it because it was so
there was just like
it was too much it was getting to be too
much and too out of control and
um like like yeah if there's one thing
about me becoming like dramatic i'm not
gonna like lie on someone that's very
easily proven
they could obviously sue me i'm not
scared to be stupid because everything
i've said is true like
and it's clearly this incident clearly
if you're paying attention to what's
going on tick tock and twitter and all
the viral videos going around
is that this wasn't a one-time incident
this is a pattern of behavior over many
years
yeah and i think that everyone keeps
missing this issue because of these
distractions like scott and jeff like
david is like perpetuating these for the
vlog like he's making this happen he
says in the vlog that's not a joke to
say
these girls weren't into it and then
after a while they're into it now like
that's not
that's not funny that's not a joke
that's like and to even like if you're
joking and pretending to look in like
why would you even want to be a part of
that like
look i don't know exactly it's david and
david's done this multiple times like
he's giving people alcohol
he says that there's another twitter i
think deaf noodles just tweeted it today
about david saying this is all my
alcohol that's how i get all my good
footage and my friends are drunk like he
admits to it
time and time again and the weirdest the
weird dude i'll tell you right now red
flag
a dude who doesn't drink who's getting
everyone around him drunk
why is he getting everyone why is he
wanting to hang out with everyone who's
drunk and he's sober
right that is someone who is taking
advantage of it david is
david's 100 i hated that his lawyers
were like david's not at fault like
david posted that if this was all a joke
and they didn't know what was that like
why would he even post the footage if it
was even questionable because it's dom
it's like why
they continue to shoot with dom
including jeff in 2019 after this
incident like
so if it's even questionable if it's
even brought up like he bragged about it
a few days later how they all looked in
on him having sex like it was
well also one of the big uh
holes in in all their stories which i'll
pull
up is that david
knew about this because i'm trying can
you highlight maybe the text message
that that dom got david got this text
message
through dom the victim sent dom a text
message about a year and a half ago when
david
deleted this film this this vlog why did
david delete this vlog because he knew
that the girl one of the girls that dom
had slept with
had sent him a text messaging accusing
him
of the artwork of a horrible thing yeah
right so
this whole like notion that david didn't
even know
is is factually uh factually incorrect
right
based on that text yeah of course no
okay so anyway
but let's watch jeff's video here's one
more thing
to say is like i i don't know jeff kept
saying when he had the phone calls me on
tuesday which i'm now thinking he
probably recorded because he said you
could record this and i was like i don't
record phone calls but he probably did
whatever it doesn't matter
but he had said something like i know
like cat's your friend like i don't know
cat she's not my friend yeah
i did one interview with the insider
about me like maybe a year ago they've
reached me sometimes i've never reached
back out to them this particular
instance i've talked about multiple
times and i was
i was so in support of this girl coming
out her story and i was there so it was
something i could comment usually i
don't comment like on jeffree star like
all that stuff i don't comment because
like i don't really give a [ __ ] but like
this was something like so serious and
something that i
was there you're in the video yeah i've
talked about it around you
jeff she reached out to everybody in the
video
like yeah you're in the video you were
there that's a reasonable thing friends
with this person
like i mean i liked your article and i
support the article but it's not like
i'm friends like i was like
yeah go get them like you know what i
mean it's like well also if you read the
article which i don't think you did
trisha is cited very little yeah like
there's like one paragraph where they
quote you
right it's such a long article i was
like okay so before we watch just video
he makes accusations in cat the author
cat released
he keeps taking snippets of their
private conversation
that he recorded and so she posted the
whole thing here i'll just play for you
before we watch this video
it's from trisha it's also from
the other girls like they remembered
that david
had asked jason to go buy the alcohol
and then trisha told jason like so
remember this because he keeps saying in
his video
only i'm only in this because of trisha
and this is proof that he knew before he
made this video
that the accuser specifically named him
don't buy the alcohol and then they said
that you and todd left and came back
with like a bottle
of i think jack and i do know like i
i have like the video like i've watched
the video so like
it was like it was like you and todd and
like that whole group was
there i don't know like if you remember
anything specific around
take the secret to the game
did you are you not hearing where she
said the other
people named you it's crazy why is he so
obsessed with you like
this is not having to do with you
because i look crazy people get like
obsessed with
your vlogs exactly but i feel like now
it's like
i'm not happy about it but it is like a
relief that people just don't think that
i'm like this bitter
like i'm totally fine in life now and i
told him on the phone too he was just
like okay well
and i don't really care about anything
other than like well these guys have
been on a brutal
um character assassination against you
for these past years to discredit
because you've been one of the vocal
people speaking out against them so
trisha is crazy she's obsessed she's
just angry because
of jason the relationship with jason but
um everything you've said is proven so
you have a right to feel relieved
because so people be like oh my god she
was telling the truth this whole time
yeah
yeah jeff was just like i was so pissed
because you lost jason brand deals
and i was like jason told me to
apologize to brandon for dating a minor
i was not okay he's like if you
apologize to brown like
jason's like awful in this situation the
tan is everything i was just like he's
awful he's done gross [ __ ] and i was
like i don't
care like i don't care because like
you're shitty people
like i'm
i've never sure underage girl's alcohol
i figured that was the case
so he i don't think he's lying i think
what he's saying is todd bought it
but he's still participating with todd
last tuesday so he's just covering
well you well he thinks well todd bought
the alcohol for himself it doesn't mean
that he got it for this girl
well did he buy the alcohol for himself
or did he not have alcohol but like yeah
you just got to own it at this point
because it's just
you're making this alcohol there you
guys brought it back maybe it wasn't
directly for the girls but
but i'm sorry i like to think that if i
was 30 years old
in that situation and there was miners
there drinking that weren't
that i wouldn't be that i wouldn't be
comfortable with that that's
like how old are you guys okay why why
and then you're
filming them and all that it's like guys
this is this is
we gotta put the pedal here we gotta hit
bump the brake on this
exactly i was like we gotta stop
somebody has got to be the [ __ ] adult
yeah i mean the only thing you can do
because they were also i mean i was just
like
i remember because somebody like just
know why and say anything it's like they
were like adults and they were like fan
girls but as soon as there was like
drinking involved under repeal i was
like okay you gotta leave
don't go buy the alcohol that's proof
that that that like there was
you sense there was something wrong of
course i mentioned this before
even before this article came i've
mentioned this for years this specific
incident
and had was there was a clip
from uh i don't know what video it was
it might have been on like the
barbershop
series there was a clip of you and todd
talking about how like you had gone to
get it but
you didn't want to so then todd ended up
getting it like
the it was like you guys had gone
together like david had asked you to get
it you were there you were like i feel
really uncomfortable doing this and then
todd was ultimately the one who ended up
buying the alcohol
he was there he's in the video
he's literally in the video picking into
the room saying i'm feeling horny right
now
and then he also says why are you saying
that he wasn't there what are you
talking about
yeah i totally get that i i know todd
was there because like he's in the video
and everything
yeah do you think it's possible that
like todd was the one who bought the
alcohol
i don't think so i know
oh he said it was 20 minutes apart and
his
dude your [ __ ] bonehead bro
it's just it's anyway so that's that's
because like you said like
todd i think is a creep brandon and
david jason but like i really don't
think jeff
i've never seen anything inappropriate
with him with girls or anything i think
he's really like that so it's like weird
that he's
once again just like scott these like
clean people are inserting themselves
like you're pretty
exactly scott and and scott
and and jeff could have just [ __ ]
rode this out
and been fine but somehow part of this
cold they feel that they need to throw
themselves
in in front of the butt well what jeff
told me and he i mean i didn't record
him but he said i could record him so i
guess it's not off the record but he did
tell me like
he's trying to distance himself from
like filming with
the group so i don't know i don't know
what this is like i guess maybe he's
still friends with todd he didn't i
don't know what it is because he said
he's not
like because i'm like why are you
defending them so hard like he said if
jason asked me to do it reluctantly like
he's very like trying to distance
himself
which is good but also why did he do
this whole video like i don't know it
was so weird
and that's getting paid is there a
technical issue i saw someone say
they can't hear me but that doesn't seem
to be right okay okay
people are trolling all right so let's
watch
jeff's video it's a slog but i think
it's important because
it's a slog it's like a we're gonna have
to group we're gonna have to uh put on
our swamp
boots and uh tread through this
um but we're gonna watch you because i
think it's important to make sure that
this conversation doesn't get
derailed which is what's happening here
because if you go like all the
david stands are saying i knew it this
this
it's making me doubt the whole story
they start to say [ __ ] like that it's
making me doubt the whole story
so because because kat and the story she
never lied and the story
has never changed okay let's watch this
this is
not how i planned this this is uh
this is a big announcement well part of
it i was waiting for this he's
noticed this is kind of funny why does
he have two cameras so dramatic oh
oh why would the camera change bro i
love it
oh you think he's hiding cuts
you're so right yeah yeah right oh
you're right he's hiding the cuts
people know how to do apology videos you
need to just be like on the floor
looking ugly on the bathroom floor bro
take a note from the girl who's trying
to ruin your life apparently
allegedly yeah
part of it i was waiting for this to be
that wasn't
cut though and i had a couple of eye
surgeries
okay from the side that part of my life
cut to the side and
that's why i wasn't on camera i was
trying to hide my i looked pretty gnarly
after the surgeries
and it's still getting better so i was
planning on coming back
when the time was right and the set was
right and i could um
get back to my old self unfortunately a
couple days ago an article came out
unfortunately this is funny
unfortunately the article came out
how awful that a girl spoke up about
something traumatic
but unfortunately something happened
that was written and i want to believe
like these you know i'm these people
you know they come out when they feel
like that it's like okay too because now
that seth being
like so many people are coming out like
more even ticked out more and more
people are coming out stories
it's a waterfall because now it's not
david's in power because he was like
look at what happened to me as soon as i
went against david everyone's just like
trisha sucks i got like canceled by
everybody that year but it's like
i think now it's it's cool that these
people also did he put that watch the
whole 20 minute or is that
he put that no he put the watermark oh
we're not going to take anything out of
context today jeff we're going to watch
the whole mother loving video
where some pretty horrible things were
said
and
i felt the need to address them because
my name was in the article and i'm
associated with these horrible horrible
acts
and i am completely 100 percent innocent
i spoke to a reporter before that
article was published
just to clear my name just because so
he's saying i'm 100
innocent that's he's already gone afoul
right you were there
there was underage drinking like why are
you trying just like you have to own
so you have to take some accountability
to say you're 100 in this clip where
you're like
yeah 100 innocent would be you weren't
even there that night you didn't even
know anything happened
okay that's 100 innocent so that's what
i'm saying like dude you have to take
some accountability even a little bit
i've i feel guilty by association just
being around david and like supporting
him for so long because
even the stuff with brandon i'm like i
kind of went along with it because you
just want to be cool in the group for a
while and you're like
i'm guilty to some degree not in this
case but i feel like in a lot of
situations like yeah i'm like
guilty by association just being with
david and like hyping him up and
covering
covering for him really like and that's
what these people are doing and it's
i mean it's just it's a ludicrous
statement you're not 100 you're in the
video like there's proof like you're
there
yeah nobody's blaming you for what
happened yeah you're not going to jail
you know what i mean i had no guilt
and not you know everyone advised me not
to talk to reporters because they'll
twist your words and
even in my past experience with getting
arrested
they'll always tell you do not say
anything because you'll incriminate
yourself
and you only make things worse and you
proof proof
of that being true you clearly
understand the concept
but uh yeah well here's me telling you
that again jeff
don't say anything innocent until proven
guilty
but in the internet world
i feel like you're guilty until proven
innocent so
if i sit here and stay quiet and try to
solve this over tweets
i'm just going to screw up more and well
that was awesome look like more of an
idiot
because you guys can't see my face one
and
two i am pretty bad at explaining myself
so i'll probably [ __ ] up a lot here
and i'll probably be picked apart but
i don't care i'm just gonna do it
because i have nothing to hide backwards
i'm completely
innocent oh is he sitting backwards in
the chair
that's pretty bad that's pretty cool is
this like that's a cool
new look for an apology video i mean he
looks cool
jeff is definitely looks cool and also
what is jeff fm is that his new podcast
was he promoting the new
i don't know if he was saying it wasn't
out yet he wasn't ready to
announce it it looks good but that
backwards shares [ __ ] cool as hell
maybe i'm changing my opinion about him
maybe he is 100 innocent
you can't do it no you need an
office chair no does anyone got a shirt
i could sit back on your knees
[Music]
it just usually just takes a second
[Music]
it just sometimes drops out for a second
[ __ ] shitty internet so this might
get picked up by the way
yeah i know that's just weird you can
hear me it's working
does any do you not have the stream open
down
so is it working
oh that's the worst this is the worst
part about going live
okay are we back guys sorry my internet
took a dump
this is the worst thing about going live
i thought l's were the thing you give
people who are losers well we definitely
take the l
and the f on this one i love that i
never knew that so are we officially
back then
oh yeah it's still smiling
well but do you see it yeah but i mean
he was seeing it where you're here
what is everyone typing in the chat it's
going so fast
i can read him faster
we are waiting for the stream to
reestablish that's what they're saying
i can hear myself asking you
it's lagging
i can hear us discussing it on the
stream this is the worst
we're back we're back okay so what i was
doing before the stream
rudely cut is i was saying i should do
we should do
the no you should do it you look cool
we're doing it we should do
this an analysis with a backwards chair
a chair i think you need like an office
chair
because like yeah first of all i'm not
even i'm not as close to as cool as jeff
first of all
definitely not and then second off he's
going to come at me with a backwards
chair how the [ __ ] am i ever going to
reply
cooler than jeff you just don't look as
cool as jeff but you're cooler than him
yeah you're like nice and respectful and
you don't i have a really good light
he doesn't lose it just kidding
no no jeff i mean mom no he refuses to
take down the sponsorships
he's not losing that coin yeah i don't i
don't i can't pull off the backwards
chair okay so we are officially back
dan is saying we're not back they're
watching us
so let's just take a moment here say
what up
we're lagging a little bit can we snip
this part out after the fact
yeah can you spam tricia heads in there
spam everyone spam trisha heads if you
hear me
let's get those tricia heads in the chat
i love them too yeah i saw them on your
last line i was like that's cool
we can add can we add more trisha flares
just ultra show emojis
well we have like a hundred emojis now
really
available slots i mean we don't have
them all filled so i'm saying
we can definitely work on some nutrition
flares
we look like twins and our beanies our
little round faces with a little bit
friend means beanies by the way first
time being
aired oh yeah we were supposed to do it
tomorrow i had a whole look plant i hate
not being glam i look like a little
also you're wearing the balenciaga meme
shirt you showed up i was like no
you're wearing the shirt i've been
wanting to wear this for you but we've
always had themes so i've been like oh
man
so so
so let's just we'll just we'll just
we'll [ __ ] around until it's better so
annoying dude should we sing
well tell me dude would you really
cruise around in that balenciaga shirt
or not i did i wore this speaking of
david i went to his 23rd birthday party
in his vlog look it up find that find
the vlog where i wore that how does it
feel to be wearing it
do you feel like like boujee yeah do you
feel like a meme
no you feel like high fashion really
yeah
i do it's a one designer item that fits
me usually people like versace only goes
up to size too
so this is like something i can rock i'm
like okay i feel skinny do you ever i
wonder if you
could wear this you can and then have
that in the back as like a cape
as a cake you can yeah you totally can
come here
we are in buffering city here folks hi
puffery we're going to cut this out
it'd be saying the audio is fine but
it's very low fps
why what's an fps frame for frames it's
just like stuttery
you're such a good boy uh i mean we've
had this happen before never this long
before though yeah like this is
it comes right back and the computer is
operating completely fine
so it just it seems to be pure like the
internet's not totally out but it's like
can they hear you talking yes
sometimes you don't and it's just and
then we're just sitting here
i think there's a lot to say about that
area we're gonna do an episode where
we're just gonna watch paint dry
yeah that's fine is this an episode well
it's not supposed to be okay
it might end up being we just stare at
jeff
does it still seem uh stuttery
choppy yeah what the [ __ ] i'm gonna
punch my router in the face
i don't know man god violent
well it's an inanimate object my
internet works fine
moses is saying either are you saying
choppy or smooth
yeah all right here's the deal i'm going
to go to the bathroom
you're right i'm going to go to the
bathroom you want to do a plug
a plug for what my music video tomorrow
oh sure yeah that'd be great
and then well we're going to cut this
out oh no but you can plug it in
okay but that's not going to make sense
we're talking about all this serious
[ __ ] and then treasure being like
watch my music video it doesn't make any
sense okay so what did i do just talk
there's a hundred thousand people
watching
oh okay okay i'll plug it i'll plug
something yeah
or something all right guys we have a
new front
what do it to your uh camera this one oh
hey guys we interrupt frenemies for a
word from our sponsors frenemies merch
coming soon to teddyfresh.com
this cool beanie is only the first of
wonderful items to come we have
zip ups tube sacks from the makers of
teddy fresher you know it's good quality
and not some shitty fan joy stuff so
look for that we also have a passover
music video coming tomorrow to my
channel so
what's up and um yeah and
um i'm sure there's a new classic teddy
fresh collection
i got a black zipper putty that's
supposed to wear tomorrow but we're not
having tomorrow
uh check out uh
check out um what else do we have to
plug
uh check out jeff whitak's response
video
actually check out the insider article
by cat read it for yourself
okay um
[Music]
you know this is 20 21 we stand by
standby victims we see them by people
saying
the truth not just his is titled my
truth and not the truth honestly
jeff whitake like i honestly don't
didn't really have any issues with you
before
this i don't know why you're trying to
like assassinate my
character i don't think [ __ ] how did you
just were there i wasn't even saying
anything
i got all my plugs in
um
oh don't stream don't stream
or maybe turn maybe turn it down to 240
if you're streaming you
sorry guys we are working hard to fix
maybe something's downloading
you know
nobody's here i know let's just do the
show
yeah just lower your i mean you guys
both streaming could affect it
no i wasn't streaming
okay okay okay okay
all right all right
so um okay we're gonna come back in
right around here
thank you everybody for sticking around
sorry about the uh technical issues what
were we talking about we were just about
to watch this video i think or we were
watching his video
all right i'll just play it yeah
whatever we were talking about
and what the what was said about me was
false before anything my heart goes out
to the victim that was a cut
yes camera shot i don't like putts in it
and these kind of
videos just ain't no cuts here actually
i just said we're gonna cut
right that's technically difficult but
you can see it all yeah that's
you can't see it all yeah and at least
this is more than two minutes long like
you know
he did oh yeah that is something i want
to say
at least if i can say anything nice
about jeff
is that he at least came out here
and talked about something yeah yeah
although it's hard to give him so much
credit when he's kind of putting cats
twitter encouraging his fans when he
called me i was like
i was so shocked he like dm me call me
he's like saying all this stuff to call
him and i was like
oh like i kind of like respected that
because honestly like that does a lot
like
just hearing from someone rather than
being like ignored or called crazy or
all the stuff they say behind your back
is like oh okay he's like because he
talked to me he's like oh you seem like
really normal and like not crazy and i
was like okay
like you know what it means thank you i
don't expect that more than
david and all these other people just
trying to i can only imagine what david
says about you
it's so funny he never missed my video
but i you know it's cool
did we drop out again okay just not to
discredit her
what dom did was horrible and disgusting
and makes me sick
and i had no idea about this until this
article was published well technically i
got reached out to to comment on it and
nobody really knew what happened that
night until that article
was sent out to us and i chose to
comment on it i chose to comment on it
because
some things that were said about me were
completely false i'm sitting here
watching these videos
where they're dissecting the article and
the video itself and the actions that
happened that night and
i am mad at myself because the way i
look
i i genuinely am upset with myself and
i know that i didn't do what they're
saying that i did but the way it looks
i can understand why people are pissed
off and i just want
so what is it that he's so people are
saying he may have bought alcohol so
that might not be true okay
but he but he keeps evading the
the main premise of course is that he
was there right he was peeking there's
that
shot of him and the vlog peeking in and
saying he's getting a body count
so it's again it's like okay let's want
to explain that and
by doing that i have to explain how
david's vlogs work
it's kind of like a chaotic
shittier version of snl david will come
up with ideas himself
but since he would have to put out so
much content other people will pitch
ideas
and sometimes he'll like him and
sometimes we'll shoot him sometimes
he'll scrap him we won't use them
um sometimes you get to do your funny
joke that you did in his video which is
the biggest platform
and that's great because then you get
more attention to your channel and and
whatever and you can maybe
get more possibilities from that bit
that you executed in his video
so on this day three years ago
um dom had posted an instagram story
where he was asking to have uh for some
he was asking who would who would be
interested in having a a foursome with
him
oh we got wind of this and it seemed
like an interesting bit
that possibly you know potentially
something funny could come out of
back when i was rolling with david and
we would film these vlogs it was very
you're shaking your head dan just this
whole explanation
on snl they don't invite random
strangers to come on and have a for like
what is this comparison this isn't a
sketch this is like this is more like a
reality show
it's nothing like snow yeah what the
[ __ ] is he talking about yeah minus like
the releases and stuff it's like
it's not it's not even like it's so it's
so odd and so weird and
who says like oh yeah that's like a good
idea let's go and film that like i don't
know
yeah and there's also a lot of
confusions about like
okay dom asked for the five sum and we
thought it would be a good idea once
again he's dodging the responsibility
where if you watch david in other clips
he's taking credit for
setting up dom explicitly stanks david
in the video
so again i feel like jeff is once again
trying to like um obfuscate the truth
by saying oh was again trying to blame
it all on dom
even though this was a collaboration for
david's [ __ ] video yeah this is also
repeated i mean like
even as like last year he was asking
like natalie and corona like how much he
could pay them to have sex with jason
and like he goes how much
can i pay you a thousand dollars david
yeah like he's on the record
and like what is wrong with him when he
thinks that sex like that
is just like some like he thinks all
women are [ __ ] or something that's
literally like and i saw someone else
say this like every girl and
everyone i never noticed like every
female in the vlog is like literally the
joke and when he's talking about like we
all came to ideas with david i'm never
why jason why does he want them to sleep
with jason
i guess because he's like the grossest
person so he's like oh how much to have
like sex with like they did it with
jonah too he's like how much has sex
with like jonah how much would it like
he asked kern of that multiple times
like because they're just gross people
why do you think that
women are prostitutes and just like sex
is just a pawn
for for entertainment yeah he's he's got
some deep rooted [ __ ] going on
but again this is jeff just once again
playing
the boys club and and and he's trying to
say it was all dom's idea and david
didn't have anything to do with it which
is something
he'll continue to say throughout this
video be like chaotic we'd bounce around
we'd be in one spot for 15 minutes
oh jesus christ that's crackling
the audio's [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in and out parking lot and see
if we can find something there we go to
hollywood boulevard we would go to
david's house or wherever and we
just keep trying to find jokes and this
situation this night is not how it
played out
in the video because you guys only see a
small small part of it
sometimes jokes don't land sometimes
shots don't work sometimes audio isn't
clean
sometimes somebody says a joke it
doesn't happen on camera
we have to but it wasn't clean yeah
too well redo it sometimes the live
breaks
sometimes things are scripted entirely i
and
david and we all were under the
impression that this
was a consensual bit these girls had
answered dom's
message to have a threesome dude again
he's he's you're
what are you talking about of course
like you are all
under the of course they weren't coming
over to be assaulted
right right and they were clearly like
fans also david has always been hiding
himself and saying that nothing is
scripted and honestly like from all my
time there nothing is
scripted like maybe they come up with
ideas but everyone that's like
the victim or get the the brunt of it
like they don't know i feel like he's
bringing that up that sometimes it's
scripted again to throw down on this
whole thing because later in the video
he says
he tries to doubt the authenticity of of
of the video and they came over to do
that or maybe pretend to do that or
joke around or just maybe nothing was
going to happen who knows
according to the article and in the
video maybe five or six girls showed up
they weren't interested in having
threesome i think they just wanted to
hang out and film
maybe some of them were or i don't know
exactly i
i remember some of them saying that they
were some were 20 some were 21
but in the article it says that trisha
who was jason's girlfriend at the time
and the one bringing all this to light
wrong it's so [ __ ] up that he
says that literally i talked about this
for years and no one cared like these
girls came forward after a lot of other
people came for i lit and then they just
asked me for a comment because i talked
about it before i was there just like
they asked you
and again this is again the same boys
club that just
uses trisha's crazy and has a vendetta
against us once again the same [ __ ]
dumbass talking point
to sell to your to your fans who ate it
up initially
right it's [ __ ] up dude you if you
read the article you would know that
this has very little
trisha's was mentioned almost none yeah
because i was only there for half of it
you were there for all of it
it's like dude what are you why are you
doing this they're an hour and a half
year they're at least
longer than that that's longer than 15
minutes like
well we'll get into that she is saying
that i supplied alcohol to loosen up
the girls which it just didn't say that
i did say
that david asked jason when jason said
no he asked jeff and jeff said i'll do
it
that's what i heard i i never said i saw
him come back but again
if it was you were the only person
saying that that might be of
interesting defense right but the part
that you don't mention once in this
whole pathetic video
is that two of the other witnesses that
were there said that you and todd came
back with alcohol
why do you not mention that dude how are
you going to come out here and and not
he's not the victim blame by just tricia
blaming which okay i'll take it but also
like there's actual people that
we're involved he's trying not to pull
scott he's trying to like do his best to
not do that but he's just he's covering
for todd who
by but who saves that based on what he
told cat in the
recording we watched in the beginning is
that he bought alcohol for himself
right so okay now stories have changed
it just makes me angry because it's so
not true
i willingly called insider to
clear my name and say this is complete
[ __ ] trisha and i have had bro you
don't clear
you this i'm sorry jeff but i just think
you must not be that smart
you don't call a reporter and clear your
name by just saying oh that's not what
happened
if you have some kind of evidence that
you can show them that might help but if
you're just going to call and [ __ ]
about say how trish is crazy just have
to get you
i don't think that's going to help
influence the article much dude right i
have a ton of things i could say about
you and todd it's like i'm not trying to
like go about that route like it's just
like that's irrelevant
also just not even has anything to do
with it because it's not about me but
it's i know it's frustrating you know we
haven't been
so friendly with each other in the past
because of
starbucks the breakup with jason my
loyalty remained with jason after the
breakup i saw trisha make videos on
jason
and she was angry at him for whatever
reasons
that's between them i reached out to
trisha personally after all this
and i mean i i only knew one side of the
story at the time i only knew
what she was saying online and he was
losing jobs losing money he was getting
hate to me in my eyes at the time it was
taking food out of it maybe because his
best friend was featured was dating a
minor maybe that's why he was losing
brand deals because he kept putting
brandon in the videos instead of me
and he was lit and it was proven that he
was dating and sometimes it's like maybe
it wasn't about me like what did i say
that i was embarrassed by jason i wasn't
angry as embarrassed he hadn't even
broke up with me
i was like you're embarrassing this is
embarrassing you're the madison beer and
tana
trying to hook up with them you're gross
and disgusting he says you were taking
food out of jason's children's mouth
which is basically saying
if anyone does anything wrong and they
have kids you can never hold them
accountable because the kids are going
to starve
apparently oh my god
shame on you are his kids still they're
fed right
i think they're okay okay good detached
my name is to this
it's just because i was the only one to
speak i talked to the reporter
and i told her that i had nothing to do
with buying the alcohol that absolutely
was not me i will go down to that okay
well the witnesses and trisha who was
there disagree right
i mean dude they literally said you and
talking from three years ago to see who
walked in the liquor store
i checked my credit card statement i
don't know how you should get those
tapes
he's got the tapes nobody's the only one
and he also said
for himself you already admitted that
you guys went in there so yeah and
my theory is we talked about this he's
probably right like maybe jeff
physically didn't do it like i saw that
david was like hey jeff just like i'll
do it and then i didn't know
yeah i don't think you did it i don't
think but to cover and say we didn't but
then i'll say oh todd bought whiskey for
himself it's like which one is it
i love this listen this is the most
half-assed [ __ ] way to defend
yourself like you have to have no brain
to actually be convicted
because he's also trying to defend todd
and david which is i checked my credit
card scene i don't you didn't check your
[ __ ] credit card statement from three
years ago
stop check the credit card statements
stop you didn't go to the [ __ ]
am pm and look do you have camera
footage from three years ago
he did show the footage oh right right
right
here's that here's my credit card
statement from that well whatever
because he didn't do it no craic but
again
it's a ridiculous claim he's missing
again missing like more of the point
he's saying he's a hundred percent
innocent maybe hundred percent
i went into hypnotherapy and i went back
in time and i remember everything
vividly
it's like okay bro yeah how do you
remember that they all said they were 20
or 21 but you don't remember that it's
like so
right you remember their exact age how
did you know their age
how did you know their age how did you
know their age jeff
it sounds like a tic-tac how did you
know you're there
you know how you how you've proved that
you didn't buy alcohol
the only one that was allegedly saying
that i bought the alcohol was tricia
wrong [ __ ] that's a lie
and he recorded the conversation did he
think cat wasn't recording the
conversation
it's like you're a [ __ ] liar bro
finding consistencies in my story he has
so many in this like mine are always the
same
even from years ago these same same
consistencies i've always said the same
truth
listen because lies are so easily if she
would wait hold on
even if let's say you didn't read the
article which i
don't think you did yeah but even if you
didn't here's cat recording your
conversation
one more time for the record
smith bought alcohol
it's from trisha it's also from the
other girls like they remembered sorry
what's he saying in response to that he
ignores
asked jason to go buy the alcohol and
then trisha told jason like don't buy
the alcohol and then they said that you
and todd left
and came back with like a bottle of i
think jack
and i do know like i i have like the
video like i've watched the video so
like
it was like the it was like you and todd
and like that whole group was there
i don't know like if you remember
anything specific around that
i did not he just says i did not
nor ignoring that it's not just trisha
which is just again like that's just not
fair characterization free
different like maybe that argument has
worked these past few years with perhaps
which is crazy everything's from tricia
yeah everything bad happening the vlog
squad is trisha's fault yeah that
doesn't [ __ ] work anymore like his
lawyer's saying that too trying to
discredit yes
which by the way i loved on your last h3
live when you said the lawyers when they
said
in their legal letter that well anyone
who knows david david wouldn't do this
and you're like what kind of lawyer is
that yeah
your honor because that's what scotty
said right
maybe it's scott that didn't wrote the
message scotty your lawyer
your honor if only you would get to know
the
defendants you could would clearly tell
that's not a legal defense you can't go
to court and be like
no of course not and also if i was his
bitter ex-girlfriend against jason i
would throw jason under the bus if i'm a
liar i'd lie about something that he did
there too i'd be like you know what yeah
save jason's life nobody's talking about
jason
and he was up david's ass for all these
bits so you're welcome jason for not
being involved in this scammy one
trisha wasn't even there when the
alcohol
supposedly so the arrived
arrived yeah wait back that up trisha
wasn't there when the alcohol
so you tristan wasn't there when the
alcohol arrived
yeah only one was allegedly saying that
i bought the alcohol was trisha
no trisha wasn't even there alcohol
supposedly arrived i told trisha who i
had
jesus yeah so many churches
yeah come on you got the second camera
for well because it'd be like this
wouldn't work
you know it's so [ __ ] up that he
characterizes you this way
because anybody that's not familiar with
the actual story is just going to be
like trisha's
this crazy bee who's just after us and
told and it's just
it's it's you're a [ __ ] liar bro and
you owe trisha apology
which is so weird because he did
apologize to me last tuesday and then he
made this video and then even when he
texted me i thought we were all cool i
was like we were until you like
because he apologized tuesday to me and
then now he's just like he was you i
just thought you were a crazy person
you're right you weren't and i'm like
what like well remember he's calling in
after this and
listen i'm not holding back i'm just
being genuine but i'm going to hear him
out
but i'm going to need an apology i think
for lying about trisha on this one
that's he don't think he got that
because i said i was like well dude you
literally lied to him
i had problems with at the time i
apologize for
discrediting everything you say because
of my loyalty to a friend
what would you do if your friend broke
up with her boyfriend
and there was some problems going on
before jump off that bridge
you would stick with your home girl
that's it that's just that's my mom that
was
your mom always say that would you jump
if kyle jumped off a bridge with you
you know that's why my name is in this
article i believe for the first time
i talked to the reporter from insider i
told her that i 100
didn't buy the alcohol i swear to god i
swear on everything dude a reporter
doesn't care
you swearing to god that's not evidence
jeff
[Laughter]
i told her i swear to god i can't
believe she included me
i swear to god and she still included me
how unprofessional
when i when a victim actually said your
name not even me take me out because
she was gonna take me out of the
question when david lawyer tried to like
throw me and she was you know
she limited a lot of what she said about
me because of david's lawyer um but
take me out the girl still said your
name jeff like i'm not like you're in
the video and the girl named you bruh
stop just stop stop it
i definitely did not i'm sober i would
not i haven't
i i know i haven't bought alcohol
because i quit drinking so i just
who bought there was no way i could have
bought the alcohol then she asked me
about a joke that i made with todd in a
video where i made fun of his drinking
problem and like how he loves whiskey or
something like that
i do make those jokes about todd so
i said yeah you know that that could
have been in a video
later years later in a completely
different situation but
i wasn't saying todd bought the alcohol
that was like
20 minutes apart in our phone call once
again he's lying we have cat
recorded the conversation and i'll pull
it up again because like i don't want to
leave any room for doubt he literally
mentions it at the end of this listen
i'm just going to skip to then i don't
have alcohol in my house
i don't you know do you think it's
possible
yeah i totally totally get that
yeah i totally get that i i know todd
was there because like he's in the video
and everything
do you think it's possible that like
todd was the one who bought the alcohol
i don't think so i know todd drinks
himself
so
wow in the same clip
so he once again is lying about the
reporter taking it out of context
it would feel like so good for like jeff
because jeff i do like we were saying i
think he's a good guy as opposed to like
david i really think he doesn't think
he's anymore
if you just like own up to [ __ ] like it
feels so good to finally like because
people like are more forgiving than you
think so if you're like hey i [ __ ] up
especially if you show
if you portray maturity yeah which he
has he has distanced himself from the
group he's deleted videos like you know
all stuff it's like okay
like it feels so good like just like i
don't think jeff's a bad guy i just
what he's doing intentionally or not is
really [ __ ] up and needs to be called
out oh yeah yeah for sure but like why
are you
lying the you literally in that clip it
sounds like you are insinuating to talk
about the alcohol just do you think it's
possible talk about the alcohol you said
i don't think so but he does
drink whiskey you said it like that but
he does drink with
me so because she said someone said it
was jack and he goes oh well he does
drink whiskey so that might make so you
knew
stop it so for you to put those two
together
it pissed me off because uh now you
you're making me look like
i'm throwing my friend under the bus i
just listened to saying that todd was
the one who
supplied this yeah i've never given a
girl a drink to
loosen girls up yeah exactly nobody's
accusing you of that dude it just sucks
because all you need to do is say
something on the inter
internet and then it's a story and then
it's it's this is a little
literal published article with a paywall
in front of it you have to pay to read
it and
the girl said to me i don't know what
video you said that in
but i didn't have much to work with and
that's what i think trisha said to me or
something
stop so that's what i had to go with
you're the only one that spoke to me
what vlog or barbershop episode did i
reference that todd likes whiskey
i just played it i just played the clip
in the same conversation for christ's
sake
uh such a headache it's like a touch of
a run around
i don't know because i know trisha has
like brought that up but i was just like
told that there was a clip of you and
todd talking about
the alcohol so for me okay now just to
give context because he's making it look
like
she's making this all up based on here's
here satriciousness is yeah
that's not true what she's talking about
is this clip she referred to earlier she
says
there's a clip of you guys talking about
it and you said you were nervous so todd
decided to buy it
she did not include that clip in the
article because she could not find
evidence of it
so you specifically asked her about that
and she said i couldn't find that clip
trying to characterize it like she was
lying about you saying todd like whiskey
even though that's on [ __ ] record
which i just played for you
douche yeah that's so dumb that's so
stupid i didn't even see those things
about cat but yeah now that's
like oh my god just straight up lies do
you think he just doesn't remember or
he's like
he's doing it on purpose like he's
trying to manipulate i don't know i feel
like he doesn't know he's
lying oof so what's the what does that
mean about him
does it mean he's just so caught up in
trying to defend when people lie you
trip over your story so much which is
why i don't like it i used to be such a
liar when i was a kid and you trip over
your story so much
and it's so easily found out so like now
i'm really careful on to like what i say
about like i always was when i made any
exposed video about
anybody anything like call roger bar
david like anybody i that's true there's
truth in it there's always truth i'm not
going to make applies i mean is he
explicitly lying because everything he's
saying is
so is so probably false like damn what's
your take on this
that's why i i mean i honestly was just
baffled by all of this
uh because it's so again he either
didn't read the article
and so or he's or he's like those are
the only two options he either didn't
read the article or he's lying
like but funnily enough even if he
didn't read the article
we have them on tape the reporters
saying it wasn't just trish it was two
other people
right well and it just it seems like he
can't get it didn't he i i was just
asking a b about this in our chat
because i wanted to make sure
i understood it but when this first
broke and you were arguing with him on
twitter the other day
trisha yeah he tweeted that he was only
there for 15 minutes
yes but everything he's stating in this
video also contradicts that so it's just
like
his story has changed like 10 times in
the last three days the 15 minutes thing
is something i really gotta ask him
about because that does not make sense
it's just not being able to keep up with
the lies which again
yeah i just i can't even keep track of
what his narrative is here
i mean if he's just outright lying then
then
you know bro i don't know i don't know
how i can help you with that one
reaching out that's why my name is in
this article i'd like to think that he's
not
being that malicious as to outright
knowingly lie but
i think he's just trying to like defend
himself and his friends any way he can
and so i think he's just
i don't know trying to throw her under
the bus me under the bus and he's trying
everything to do not to victim one
because that didn't go too well for
scotty so i think he's just trying any
other route
[Music]
i don't know that's why i'm associated
with this back to explaining how david
films
we do stuff that sometimes doesn't work
and that bit in our eyes all of our
eyes it was a failure it didn't work out
and
we all left thinking it didn't work out
so why was it posted
why would he have posted it and i also
brag about it on a podcast and two days
later
if you didn't think that worked out
that doesn't make sense that claim
doesn't make sense they filmed the whole
thing
they got dom having the threesome they
were peeking inside the door
i mean i just i don't know what is his
point of trying to bring this up
it was a failure guys that he just left
and that was it
right i guess the room we were like oh
they went in the room with him but
nobody's clothes were taken off
no nobody was kissing did you know that
nothing's going on we were just joking
around
and then we left straight up we left we
went somewhere else to film something
else
in the video so that that claim is hard
to know
what's the truth or not but but the guy
has not been truthful about everything
else so i'm inclined not to believe him
in this case
well he also says that he didn't he
looked in and like nobody was in there
but now he looked in and they were fully
closed no one was kissing
they were fully clothed nothing was
happening so why in the vlog does dom
come out naked
and why is david also in the article cat
says that she has a a recording that one
of the
witnesses took of them saying did you
see anything to david and david saying
no he locked the door
right which is what he did because the
guys kept peeking in when they were
trying to hook up
so again this doesn't hold water
compared to the accounts of what
happened that night
and even what's in the vlog which has
dom coming out naked saying stop
bothering me and once again you're not
innocent because you're partaking in
this even if you're peeking in on them
clothes you're partaking in something
like
you're still you're still not innocent
these are like young fan girls obviously
drinking whether you brought the alcohol
or they just had alcohol or
they were drinking like you're a part of
this like no did you know they weren't
naked when you peeked in right i know
what i mean
yeah and they said and i i was there
when they said they didn't want to do it
they just wanted me david
not the main girl because she said she
didn't know who we were whatever but the
other girls were just so excited to meet
david and me and everyone they said it
so they were fan girls they said they
had no intention of hooking up with them
they just want to like hang out and
chill so you know
that part but now then they're in the
room yeah that's
and also jeff looked in and came out and
said oh they look pretty good
so uh he did say that you're a [ __ ]
third it looks like we were peeking in
and in the article it says that the
friends had to
lift her limp body out of the room
because she drank so much alcohol
that was supplied allegedly by me or
todd
and that sounds absolutely horrible and
i won't stay silent on this i don't give
a [ __ ] how this gets picked apart
go ahead i would never look into a room
and see
again you are bro i don't i'm sorry to
say this with peace and love i think
you're just dumb
i think your all your problems in life
probably just stem from you being kind
of an idiot
yeah the article does the article says
that they had to go in there after you
guys had already dipped out
because her lifeless body was dumped and
kept on the bed
when you it's clear from the timeline of
the article
that they were not she wasn't blacked
out and dumped on the bed naked when you
peeked in there
right like what yeah what are you
talking about
according to you you said there was
there were clothes or whatever so they
were but they were still in the bedroom
with this guy
like in new breeded is that the word yes
again it's like bro you're it's like
he's trying to make this big stand on
this point that literally
doesn't even matter and already you guys
are all you know they're fans of all of
you guys there's these girls
so once again there's like this power
dynamic of david you todd
all of us being there and it's just like
you're still like there's still like a
problem here you're like drinking with
these fan girls so there's this really
and you know they're fans of you guys
and
it's just it's just i believe you that
you didn't see it
that the article clearly states that you
weren't there when it happened
come on dude girl being
and allow that to happen i believe
david and dom where he said you guys all
but now he's kind of throwing and trying
to throw and to doubt the authenticity
of the entire story of course yeah
even though he goes i'm not here to look
them she anymore but
doing that by missing the whole [ __ ]
point both end up in jail together and i
said no they separate the
the race and the pedophiles and stuff
like that they they separate those guys
and they put them in different color
outfits and
they give them special security because
they get beat down and they get killed
because of what they do when you're in
jail and you're a racist that's what
happens to you
they give you like the light blue
jumpsuit and
the rest of us would be in dark blue
look i i've [ __ ] up before in the past
i've made mistakes i've addressed them
they're on the internet you could read
through every one of them and i'll admit
to them if i did something wrong i'll
admit to it this was
all nearly a decade ago and i have
nothing to hide now
look i referenced jail a lot and it's
become a part
what he's saying he went to jail a
decade ago making it sound like the
video was a decade ago kind of
my character i guess and i haven't been
there in 10 years but
what i can say is it's it's a horrible
place it's where
nobody would ever want to be what's that
got to do with anything the second you
get there especially in california you
have to fight
and okay bro jail's tough what what am i
supposed to do with this
even the most hardened criminals even
the worst people on the planet that i
have to be locked in a cage because they
can't be out in society
still do not condone rape
and sexual assault and pedestal so so
his argument here is that because he's
gone to prison he's against
essay which clearly he's not because he
knew about the text with dom and these
girls in 2019 he still filmed with
dom after this the ones from vidcon he
knew all this but he may not have known
about the text we don't evidence of that
i'll tell you i know for sure the whole
group knows about dom and his
that's for sure the vidcon thing but the
facts and he still did videos with him
had a whole barbershop episode like you
did you still probably heard them
after the whole vidcon controversy why
did you continue to associate with dom
i mean i have that same question for
everybody this poor girl was
was straight up assaulted by dom and
everyone was allowed in him as a hero
for
admitting to his mistakes legend
defiles i don't stand for any well he's
been to jail so so he's fine he's been
to jail and
as you know in prison we don't stand for
that [ __ ]
oh is that what he's trying to say yeah
i got it he's like trust me
i don't think anybody does i don't have
to go to jail tonight i agree
that's like saying anyone who's been to
jail would never come out and commit an
assault or something
we're all rehabilitated dom is gonna get
what's coming to him i've been reaching
out to him because he needs to address
this because since i'm the only one who
will talk
i'm the one that's getting the most [ __ ]
that's not why and i called dom several
times a day
uh i've been texting him and he said
stop calling me and i said it doesn't
work like that
i'll just [ __ ] read it because i i
mean who gives a [ __ ]
i'm an open book i got nothing to hide
he said on a call bro
is that true is he open book except well
no you're
you've deleted all your videos you're
not an open book you literally will not
admit that you went to the store
yeah with todd and you keep saying you
were there for 15 minutes you can't have
anything wrong like if someone's just
innocent everything like admits i'm
wrong doing 100
uh not yeah stop calling me i said
i said stop calling you it doesn't work
like that i i ended off with saying
you better hope the cops find you before
i do i mean i don't even know what i
would do
this video i don't know why he got to
include like threats of physical
violence well this is coming from the
guy that left his coffee when he saw me
in a starbucks
guy i think that's nothing that
triggered him because when i saw that i
was like this is the guy that's
returning he's like
i've been in prison i'm [ __ ] tough
and then like when he saw me like did
not get his coffee
so that's why i said it because i just
felt so funny everyone's always so
scared of jeff and i was like
you're not gonna do anything like
it it's fine and you went to jail for
selling marijuana like i mean you know
it's legal now so it's like you don't
act like you're like oh they
find your party you know where he is
like this whole situation makes
well i don't think he should go beat up
dom no no no i'm not either i'm saying i
i would encourage you not to do that
definitely don't be sick
or don't be yeah mean just want you guys
to know that
i would never just sit back and watch a
girl get [ __ ] i agree nobody's saying
you did that
i would never sit there and let that
happen yes we know nobody's saying that
you know the video is being picked apart
lined up with the article and it looks
bad
i i'm mad at myself when i watch it you
know i have nobody's thing
i don't think anybody's saying that when
they peeked in they saw
the that they knew that a girl was being
like
that's not i don't think that's the
timeline that right am i wrong or is
people do people think that
i think just the overall watching girls
yeah i think they're not consenting to
it they're
drunk they're not going to be watching
them they're not consenting to you guys
peeking in it's the same thing as like
the shower situation me and jason like i
mean it's not like there was anything
inappropriate other than like i didn't
like know something
today having sex you know yeah that kind
of thing
yeah i have respect for all women but
back to perspective
david vlogs i don't respect it it's all
women
like i don't respect all people
maybe like yeah i respect i respect all
you know
i respect all women no i don't no
exception i don't respect jodi arias the
girl who stabbed her husband 41 times
i don't respect casey anthony exactly
you know what i mean so
not all women oh dan's coming out with
margaret against margaret
thatcher ladies and gentlemen we have
the next episode we need to cancel
charles dickens he was anti-semitic
troll we're going way back huh i just
saw that recently
yeah right after i can't tell you i have
it in my notes for real yeah you might
as well put yourself on that list
no i'm not oh my god you might be anyway
also can we go back to this the also a
big issue is
david david also again once again being
like go buy alcohol for these girls
but it's a theme that he's admitted to
saying he has his best bits when his
friends are drunk so he has alcohol in
hand like he admits this
this is something that's enough always
bring in the alcohol yeah so of course
maybe you didn't do it and like again no
one's really coming for you this is
david's vlog
david produced it david orchestrated
david asked people to go get alcohol
like i was there for that like it's not
he wasn't he's not really under fire you
know what i mean he put himself in the
[ __ ] crosshairs and now he's gonna
get mowed down
it's obvious that you know things are
scripted and set up and reshot i've said
that
already but there is a clip at the end
of the video and it's with dom with a
shirt off and he's
[ __ ] sweating that shot was not even
shot that day
again proof that he didn't read the
article because they say that in the
article yeah
they literally said it in the article
this isn't a revelation bro
right and i know people will probably
take this clip
right now of me saying this and
everything said is a statement and
everybody's story needs to match up and
you can take this
and you can use this in court this is my
statement i'll [ __ ] stand on the
stand
say this again i was not there
david went back the next day to shoot
that sweaty scene
they literally sprayed him to make him
look sweaty we know that again we talked
about it what's sick about that is that
david must have known this girl was
blackout and puking and all this and
then they went back to complete the bit
yeah which is even crazier right it's
even crazier
holding exactly maybe and make it look
like he just finished having sex
to my understanding that was shot the
next day
in the article dude and to my
understanding
david had no idea that dom had just a
girl
that night before when he told him that
he successfully had the threesome
so they can sure i believe david didn't
know that that's what happened but what
david did know is that the girl was
puking black out drunk and apparently
you knew that too jeff because you were
there all night
yeah and had to re-shoot it and
furthermore the dave was like last
apology like he knew this from dom's
text that he sent in february of 20 when
i made my video
so like david still knows this and still
hasn't taken accountability so why
you're defending this person
david removed this video a year and a
half ago for a reason yeah he knew all
of this i don't know you know all of
this like this is in the present and
you're still like
no you know now
finish the bit they have the ending to
their story what happened i had no idea
about i could speak for myself
in my opinion david went into that
thinking that this was a consensual bit
and it was funny to him at the time when
he was 21 again
nobody went there expecting to be
assaulted and literally he says
in the vlog these girls weren't having
it and then a couple hours later
read between the lines david larry goes
it was clear that
he did fivesome wasn't happening but dom
got to got
persuasive there's a vlog that was
circling around at me and jason later
that i in bed being like yeah we tried
to set up a dog
of five some for dom he said we tried to
set up a fight some for dominant didn't
happen
yeah and i said this is something you
can't really set up is it
like it's out there like this is not
they set it up and it didn't work and
everyone knew that and
going to buy the alcohol for them was
like the solution
you know i guess his friends out here
that you know why he's called my truth
because it's not the truth i hate that i
know
i just hate that [ __ ] you're from vernon
hills together is it the truth no it's
not it's not true
people use that way through easily now
this is my channel and he's able to have
a threesome from putting out
an instagram story it was cool to him i
don't control the
what goes in thanks david that's what it
was cool to him at the time
the joke that was made at the end of the
video saying that we should
we'll probably all go to jail for this
was
a complete joke and a terrible what's
the joke that is so [ __ ]
what's the joke though right
okay obviously it's a joke what's the
joke jeff explain to me
the premise after all of that that whole
night of like the girls the sex like
you're like and then
what's the joke what's the premise of
your joke jeff
why are you going to jail in your joke
and it's so funny it's david brandon and
like literally the people i've called
out
the slimy ones because it turned out
something horrible actually happened
that night
but do you think it in anyone's right
mind
if we just posted a video to 10 million
people that a
serious disgusting crime happened in we
would make a joke saying we're going to
go to jail for this
no but it's telling yeah yeah
right exactly good point dan i
definitely wouldn't expect you guys to
go back and complete the pick
and then no i think what it means is
that there was some underlying
unease about it that made you guys
created make that joke
because clearly that's the joke yeah
otherwise what's the job what is the
joke what are you going
you know joke i didn't know what
happened i just think people
if they're innocent they should talk i
woke up today to
a call from my manager where i was asked
to delete
all the posts that i've done with a
brand that i've been partnered with for
a while and
i felt like angry at first and you know
disappointed
i didn't feel guilty i felt like this is
now costing me everything i've worked
for i refuse to delete it
and this i love that's crazy
that's so crazy that that's what you're
like upset about it's like [ __ ] i'm
losing brand deals
well oh here let me play i shouldn't
pause it and he said they could sue you
and i said you know what then [ __ ] it
let him sue me i'm innocent and i know
how this looks your innocence has
nothing to do with the brand
which is in a contract like jeff is on a
mission to ruin his life
literally yeah jeff please for the love
of god when i saw this i was like dude
just take it down
bro please and if you ever want to work
with a sponsor again this is not the way
to do it
because i think your association and
david's blog alone regardless of the
article just like what you did in that
vlog is reason enough for a brand
not to want to partner with you like now
until
until it cools off right because again
you're not the main perpetrator
yeah like let it cool off give them what
they want just remove it
because now you're known as the guy who
if [ __ ] goes down he's going to make you
sue him to remove the boats like i'm
sorry that's not someone
any brand is ever going to want to work
with bro just say i'm sorry i understand
the situation
i'm going to take it down even though of
course
it happens you know it happens you don't
fight you don't say i'm not taking [ __ ]
you i'm not taking it down
i've never had that happen i don't have
brand deals so i don't know what that's
like
apparently adam eve doesn't care adam
you just yeah right or die
when the podcast was going to end they
when we thought we didn't we're going to
continue like oh are you continuing the
podcast are we should we keep sponsoring
like
they they oh when they thought you were
gonna oh that's they're like should we
just like
pull out oh that's nice yeah loyalty i
like that maybe i own adam and eve i
don't know how
you should at this point i think you're
the only reason they're
floating they're like we will never pull
ads on trisha
i love they're like just tell me what to
do you're quitting the pockets just tell
me i'll [ __ ] cancel all of them
they've used to buy me through every
single thing i've been through i love
that i love that they're loyal to you
yeah i'm not mad about that at all
adam and eve get adam and eve as a
sponsor jeff who's the one that sponsors
oh chipotle apparently they they just
love supporting
yeah yeah chipotle's like just for just
sponsor absolutely anything
james david and the spring chicken
burrito is james's burrito
he likes them yellow yeah i like that
yeah he loves the unit people like the
big [ __ ] burrito too my breeze the big
[ __ ] yeah
well what can i say they serve spring
chicken there and that's how joe and
that's how james charles likes
his meat young
and he's just living his life oh yeah
he's living his best life for sure james
charles ladies and gentlemen
yikes anyway what a mess
and you know i do feel bad because it's
like jeff is getting all this heat but
like james charles
is a billion times worse and he's out
there living his best life with the
young
chicken spring chicken burrito
wait stop calling why that's what he
loves i just hate it
i hate it so much well you know what
spring chickens are right
yes yes i understand
okay but i will speak up and i will
show that i'm not who these people are
saying i am
removing those those problems from those
partnerships
it looks like i'm admitting guilt and i
i know he's saying that it's
the thing like if it's names and titles
and you're speaking yeah it's just being
respect yeah
exactly it's not to be associated with
you at the moment no i don't know if his
problem is that like
i don't know if it's like he said post
that makes me think like twitter or
instagram or something but
if there's like a whole episode you can
jeff i'm talking directly to you if
you're watching you can just clip out
that part
right you can keep the video up yeah i
don't know you had no problem taking
down like dom and all these other videos
like just take that one down like it's
not
just clip out the part though because
maybe he's got like a whatever i don't
care jeffy's
[ __ ] like that now jeffy deal with
your [ __ ] bro you were there just i
don't know it's tell you about jeff
you're linked to this but i'm [ __ ]
innocent i didn't
assault a girl i didn't know i wasn't an
accomplice to an assault
i know tagged along to make a a skit
to make a consensual bit i'm not trying
right it wasn't again that's another way
of trying to
flex everyone's and everyone's involved
in the skit snl i'm pretty sure they're
all aware they're filming
100 yeah yeah defend anybody here i'm
just trying to tell the truth
and i'm not media trained i i probably
[ __ ] up a blessing
i mean i talked to trisha and can you
tell me
i mean that was a lot to call her after
she said some who even said that i'm not
crazy stuff about me but i always feel
like communication
should be done offline and i'm always
quick to call and talk things out
without them blowing up online so
everybody else has their two cents in
without knowing the whole story
and i called trisha and i immediately
apologized for the starbucks situation
she's allowed to have an opinion the
legendary star
if only would have said hi to you at
starbucks none of this would have
happened
it's like just so not what it's about
because i didn't say yeah kicking
himself
i was ignoring him the same way he was
ignoring me we were both avoiding each
other i was just saying how funny he
talked about jeff is
thinking about that starbucks encounter
over and over again is he trying to be
like condescending or is he being
serious i don't know is he being genuine
like i'm sorry i don't know
well i think he's being serious but it
does come off condescending because he
isn't flying like
that this whole starbucks thing is the
reason why
you know everything's crushing down on
his life right now
and me the loyalty to my friend
is what got me into a beef i mean this
allegation in here there's no beef
could potentially ruin my life and
career and everything i worked for
this article currently cost me every
partnership i've worked my entire
life to build and it's all just because
i was trying to help by telling the
reporter the truth no
no now you were named you're calling
me come on dude you know what i also
like you're again a guilty by
association like i was dropped for my
podcast last year with uh
what was coming podcast one because of
shane's scandal so it was ryan for real
rylan was dropped from spotify and i was
dropped from podcast one they they said
it was because they couldn't afford me
but i've seen shows like like 100
views and they still sponsor and it's
because it's because my association with
shane so even i had nothing to do with
shane's
allegations because i was associated
with him like you know you get dropped
that's what it is
it's better to you know i wish i would
have separated back then but i was so
like true i was like
so hardcore and stuff like that it's
better when you just separate yourself
especially if you if you are
not guilty and you're seeing all the
things that your friend is guilty of
david is clearly guilty of this stuff
and you're still trying to associate
with him it sounds like todd too yeah
that's true if you really wanted to save
your career and do the right thing you
would say
you know what i bro what can i do i
can't rewrite history for you you [ __ ]
up i'm not going to say here
say it because you know that i'm telling
you it goes a long way i [ __ ] up so
many times and if you're just like [ __ ]
i [ __ ] up especially when it's not
true
say it don't come out here and say
you're 100 innocent brah
yes reporter if she was sorry do you
still want to call in is he ready can we
get him on standby because we're almost
done
he may have bailed i've been like [ __ ]
these guys
oh yeah i have this can you send me the
zoom like sen send it to eli she's my
phone she's going to send him to zoom
link on my twitter dms
all right let's get him ready for
twisting my words and causing all this
now because um i'm sure she had a an
idea
about you know what what the aftermath
this would be but
um i just wanted to know if she had any
any sort of sympathy for you know
knowing that i was innocent
and still doing this yeah and i even
have she keeps saying that she knows
you're innocent
what do you mean because you're not i
don't think he understands what like
you're not innocent
like you didn't do yeah no one's
accusing you of like doing anything but
like you're not
the witnesses said you came back with
alcohol yeah you were a part of this
group you were part of this but i swore
to god but i when i was on the phone
with her i said i swear to god
and she's still included literally
scott's defensive like everyone knows
david's a nice guy he would not
daniel you hacked into my mainframe can
you play the video
oh yeah thank you into me on the phone
that
she believes me that i'm innocent but
she still went ahead and twisted my
words wrong so [ __ ] it i'll put the
video in
jeff i am i am very very sorry to hear
that
like i feel like you were more of an
innocent well
i feel like you were more of a bystander
though right and i'm
very sorry that that is headed your way
i don't think that anything else is
going to come out that will like
involve you specifically because are you
sorry to hear it or are you sorry that
like you
wrote you worded it that way though like
it sounds like
like i mean i'm sorry to hear it because
ultimately like i had to
do that for my job like that's just like
what i had
to do with the information that i was
presented with but i am sorry to hear
that yeah don't
told her you were there so she had to
report it so once again he's insinuating
that she's knowingly lying and that she
ruined his life and all this [ __ ]
dude again he if the most the most
ironic thing is he's doing to her what
he claims she did to him right
here she says
um she says the thing i'm saying i'm
sorry about
is that jeff before asking if i was
sorry he told me people were calling him
an
r word and a p word a p a p
word and his life was being ruined and
stuff and she was like yeah i'm sorry
that's like on a human level
i'm sorry that's happening to you it
doesn't mean that she lied
so you were taking her words out of
context yeah she reported what the girl
told her that you brought back alcohol
[ __ ] because
all i got to do is release the rest of
this phone call and
you know i'm not trying to get people
fired that's not my goal
i understand you're trying to get a
story out about a serious
crime that was done to a girl and i
support that
but what you did was not do good
research
wrong and you brought down a lot of
innocent people along the way
and you put a paywall on it you claim
you're helping the girl
you know you claim you're helping the
girl by getting her story out there but
why put a pay wall on it why make people
come to [ __ ]
it sign up to insider welcome to
actually running a business
like that doesn't discredit the article
it just means also she's the author she
doesn't
she's i'm sure that she had nothing to
do with the article there are times does
it too there's
even the thing my vulture was behind a
paint while i paid for that everything's
finally well
yeah they're running a business it's not
easy to make money in that world they
had lawyers talking with david's lawyers
yeah
that doesn't delinea legitimize that he
really delved into it the story was come
out like a week prior and they had to
like delay it because their lawyers were
involved and
she did plenty of her oh he's taking
over my
[ __ ] here like
it's for your own personal profit
you said it i had nothing to work with
and you're the only one that spoke to me
that's the only reason i'm in this
message no
and that's the only reason stop lying i
am dealing with what i'm dealing with
now
now you're named losing partnerships
that me and my team work to build
you know i'm not the only one that works
on my videos i have
i think about 10 employees now on
payroll
that rely on me to eat and
oh no not the food argument again
they're going to starve
it sucks i agree it [ __ ] it's
horrible it sucks i feel for you bro
these people are going to starve to
death now along with jason's kids
they'll never eat again because you
[Laughter]
rely on brand partnerships to
be able to put videos out for free and
it's all ruined now because of this
[ __ ] article because of you
why were you there i have no guilt in it
whatsoever
[ __ ] reporter put her put her [ __ ]
twitter up
acting like you're doing the lord's work
don't act like you're doing the lord's
work
you're doing this for profit again i've
said this a hundred times this video
okay now you've gone too far yeah you
said too much
just like a straight-up attack so which
part is it if she's doing is she doing
the lord's work no
is she bringing light to this horrible
crime which you apparently want to
assault dom for
no she's doing it to make a profit
as the owner of insider
and the fact that he says he has your
girl and also for the record all my
videos like the one i made about david's
apology they all get to monetize like
anything about david gets to monetize on
my end too so it's not like
everything's for profit it's just also
and two the fact he has no guilt like i
have guilt about it i'm like maybe i
should have done more you know what i
mean like you have to have some sort of
guilt like
i feel guilty let's say we're grown
adults and like yes we left or whatever
like that but i feel guilt about it how
do you not like when these girls i don't
know if
these girls are different girls that are
telling me about the situation if it was
in the group i remember saying like
[ __ ] i feel really bad because they said
they were fans awesome i wish i would i
wish i would have said more and stuff
like that so to feel
no guilt is actually like psychotic like
you're actually kind of like evil you
have no sympathy you lack empathy and
then also to say put this bitch's
twitter up like here you know like that
was so
a lot and then be like oh she's acting
like a good guy but she's just here to
make money and lie about all of us like
bro come on
stop like you you admitted yourself that
this is a good article
this whole thing about dom is good so
why are you trying to discredit the
whole [ __ ] thing
i don't think major brands would be
dropping you and david and all these
people just because if there was just
some silly allegations like these are
some serious [ __ ] that's been backed up
that's been corroborated that's like
verified multiple people it's not one
incident not to instance multiple
different people that don't know each
other this has been happening too so
maybe
it's you guys who did these vlogs and
you're you're getting the repercussions
from it
yeah and rightfully so when there is no
sympathy like there's i mean sympathy
well was jeff popularized through the
vlogs or yeah oh my god no one knew who
jeff was before
how did he get involved with david i
don't know he oh todd
so todd's friends with todd yeah so todd
brought him into the group because it's
like dude these are kind of like
ill-gotten gains in a way like your
whole
empire is built off the back of these
vlogs that were shot with like kind of
you know
built on a shaky foundation which is
like a house of cards it's all tumbling
now so i mean you kind of just got to
accept it and keep like your life is not
over bro you can still
bro i've lost sponsors so many times you
just got to keep sl slogging forward bro
okay
especially when you're not the one
having these like yeah you didn't you
jeff just don't lie because now you're
now your character looks bad anytime you
say anything now people aren't like oh
the victim but if it's such a serious
story
get the facts straight this is a
criminal case now get the facts straight
what facts are wrong don't just throw
around oh this person might have done
this because
trisha said yes the
witnesses said it best organizations
that help
survivors of salt now then he's trying
to like discredit
all of insider i don't know what he's on
yeah well it's like he's promoting like
i don't know
yeah anyway is he right is he ready to
come on
uh did you send him the link
no you have my phone
we'll just send okay
okay you got the link uh dan did you
send me somewhere
here i'll just keep playing it so you
guys can well from insider
five of the best organizations that help
survivors of salt
now april is health awareness month and
prevention month
so there you go
go hunt down the bad guys next month
goddamn insider always want you to sign
up or pay for something
they're gonna slander me again man here
we go april is salt awareness month
also referred to as salt awareness and
prevention month across the nation
if you or someone you know has
experience
i don't know maybe he's trying to give
awareness to people okay
nice we like that once it's about jeff
then you can't say anything
so i sent jeff's a link he just sent me
a message a few minutes ago saying he's
ready so i think he is going to
okay oh i thought he was gonna flip the
switch
he seems eager to talk so first of all i
mean props to him for coming out
i think that too you know oh hey we're
here
hey trisha was oh oh hold on one sec i
hear you but i need to
move your your uh dana you're gonna have
to
okay wait i see it okay one second jeff
dan my man my favorite i i love all the
nice things you said about me so far
i'm really enjoying this i haven't been
listening damn which one
of course i'm listening okay
especially the one with scott i i mean
this one was interesting to be
like to hear you guys tear me apart
which i get you know i'm here to learn
today too i'm not just here to
uh voice might you know to be fair i
feel like we were being pretty i
i'm i've always been pro jeff i never
thought you were creepy or slimy in the
group of all the people i'm like jeff
seems to be the least problematic of the
group so i was just a little shocked to
see your video i guess because
even when we talked you seem very normal
and like
i don't know just not i don't know great
then i guess i could you know
i could start this off with an apology
can you guys hear me good yeah is it the
mic
yeah i can hear you you're fine up here
this is yeah so
i could start this off with an apology i
apologize for calling you crazy and not
uh validating your opinion you know um
i know the starbucks thing has become a
meme now and
you know i i i got myself a keurig
so i won't be happy to go down there
anymore and
you know i i i talked about in the video
but i did a shitty job i said i'm bad at
this stuff you know
well okay let's let's talk about
something specifically
you said a bunch of times in your video
that trisha
is the reason you're in this article did
you did you read the article
i didn't want to pay for the paywall on
it yeah
no i listen i i don't want to make any
jokes i just have it
sarcastic tone like i i want to be clear
that i'm here
too do you acknowledge that it wasn't
trisha just saying that
now after listening to you guys uh
addressing the article a bunch of times
yeah i understand
so you really didn't read the article or
were you joking no listen so i'll start
from the top and like i said you know
i'm not here to discredit the victim at
all and i want to make that clear i'm
not i'm just here
to explain my side of the story and the
reason i'm even coming on here is
because i genuinely feel like you know
this there are some misunderstandings
here and we could just clear it up if we
talk it out
and you know it's tough because you guys
just picked me apart called me dumb
yes and you know the chair is i mean you
can't see it but i'm sitting
i'm sitting in the cool way you know
yeah
yeah um these actually i could send you
the link after
that's fine but but jeff let's let's try
to remain somewhat serious here because
i feel like you're trying to charm me
with your uh humor
yeah and that's but but like so okay
i feel like first of all let's just
acknowledge
you kept saying in that video that trish
is the reason
that the article said that you got
alcohol the witnesses
okay two witnesses there said that you
came back with todd with alcohol
yeah so let me start from the beginning
when i first got reached out to by
um insider the the reporter
um i like immediately i was like oh what
is this my name in an article with dom
and sexual assault like
i'm gonna call right away before i had
the facts straight this was three years
ago so
you know stupid move you're right i'll
give it to you
that was dumb to call a reporter when i
i don't even know i don't think she
mischaracterized you either so i got to
stop you there a little bit too
okay so when i called her um she
referenced
that she heard from well at first i said
i 100 didn't buy the alcohol you heard
that in the clip
and then later on in the clip she said
oh yeah but i have a video that i heard
from trisha that you said in a barber
shop that you admitted
to buying alcohol with todd for these
girls
and i was like i do make fun of todd for
his drinking problem all the time
so that is possible that i said that
todd does drink whiskey
but if this is in a barber shop video
that was years later
how is it tied to this story here and
this is on paper like i i mean
i did record it i have her saying that
trisha told her that there was this
barber shop you made this video
after the article came out so i don't
understand no no no
this this barbershop episode no no the
video your response video came out aft
well after the article after everyone
had dissected it so i don't understand
that anecdote
who bought the alcohol did you and todd
go to the store to buy the alcohol
no 100 percent know
we said todd had bought whiskey for
himself yeah
well look i could speak i could speak
for myself and you know i was
i didn't okay i don't know i know i go
ahead
i can't speak for anybody else did todd
not
himself did todd by himself whiskey no
i to my understanding todd didn't leave
the apartment and i know the girls say
this and
it's so tricky because why wasn't there
alcohol at the apartment
there was alcohol at the apartment okay
there was alcohol department we don't
know where it came from
i mean did you know that girls were
underage
no you said they were either 20 or 21
years old
yeah to my understanding yeah so you did
know that some of them were underage
well it's it it's 20 underage for
drinking
yes that's what i mean by underage yeah
so you were aware that they were
underage
drinking alcohol there i didn't
know which ones were drinking okay right
that's fair
but i didn't i i got to be honest like i
i
tag along for these videos and i know
how it looks i saw
your guys's videos where you broke down
that vlog
and i'm i would love to go through it
because
you know this situation was three years
ago so i don't want to come on here
and stutter and sound like i'm going to
lie because i don't know i remember the
story exactly this was over
well i'm assuming you had time to
refresh your memory by now
if you're going to go out and make that
whole apology video let me ask you this
you say you were there for
15 minutes do you stand by that still no
i was there for probably 30 45 but i did
go home i didn't stay were you there the
whole night
no so you say we were there for 30
minutes so he let me
can he see this photo i pull up down
here well you can look at the stream i
guess
if that's possible what i have here is a
photo
at the end of the night
taken at 1 18 a.m from one of the
witnesses
one of the girls there it has in it
all of you guys outside todd
you jonah david i don't see the photo
anymore
it'll pop up on the stream and then what
and then what what you see here
is one of the girlfriends holding up
hannah who was the victim
because she's blackout drunk you can see
her here being held up right here
and all of you guys there now
still don't see it so
it'll be there in a moment so what this
proves
and then i'm assuming you were there
when the girls arrived they arrived
around 11 so that means you were there
for two hours
okay yeah to my recollection i wasn't
there for two hours
doesn't mean this photo's timestamp that
1 18 a.m
this was given to me directly from um
from one of the people and you're
sitting next to me at the vlog when me
and jason are still there we vlogged
later that night at about 11 30 a.m
saying we left
yeah and it's the end of the night and
that girl's clearly
so this being held up so this is after
the the you know attack happened right
and so so according to the the account
of the events
she was puking and clearly very very
very intoxicated
and you guys are all there so i have a
hard time believing that
the guy all the guys there including you
and dave and all you guys didn't know
that this girl was like
borderline black i i certainly wasn't
there when they were having sex
well sure they were in a private room
you weren't in the room no i wasn't even
in the apartment
so you weren't sick at all so you left
and then you came back
at the end of the night i guess i did
come back yeah
you know as ridiculous as it sounds but
i live down the street
my apartment is literally a block away
from that apartment complex
so you know trisha you
you know how things go with david he's
constantly calling you to film stuff
and redo stuff redo takes
and at the time like yeah i regret being
a part of that video
of course but if you saw her blacked out
why wouldn't you say don't post this
like i mean you say david gives consent
to everybody everyone's like oh david
says
whatever everyone gets consent to why
would you not post that you're 30 and
these girls are blacked out
you're standing right there with a girl
being like held up i mean at the time i
was 27 which is
not an excuse but it's
i mean i don't remember that
i genuinely don't remember that it's
like a group of fan girls are given
alcohol i was like we need to leave i'm
not the brightest school in the shed but
i just thought okay
i did leave you around the time after
you left i did head out i went home
and i possibly came back and then when
you were like looking in the room you
said nobody was in there
no i didn't say that i said i i watched
him go in the room but at the time
nobody was drinking nobody was kissing
people were fully clothed
and we were pretending to see stuff
so later on the author of the article
was given a video
by one of the witnesses of someone
asking david did you
see them and he said no dom locked the
door are you aware that dom locked the
door
were you there when dom locked the door
i didn't get that far into it i was
already gone
i was gone by that point i didn't stick
around
so you know people are in and out of
that place it's it's i know how it
sounds like it's somebody's house but
that place is more looked at to david as
like uh
i mean dom lived there but at the time
david looked at it as more of like a set
where he would just pop in and film and
we would all be in and out of there
and you know i never really knew too
much i didn't i wasn't
a part of the planning of any any of
these bits
you know like i said sometimes i'll
suggest ideas but david rarely you
use my ideas um are you guys like all on
a group chat about this because it's so
weird you're so
blindly defending them when they're like
david's at fault for the most of it
and todd has his own issues when you're
you're not really at fault for any of
this but you're
going so hard to just prove i'm crazy
cat's the worst and instead of like
blaming david who filmed this who
corroborated all this who was there for
the entire thing
well i can only speak for myself really
you know i talked to todd and genuinely
he told me that he didn't buy the
alcohol
and i you know alcohol was there
their girls drank i didn't see them
drinking i wasn't there for that
but again this is so long ago it's tough
for me to really bring this all together
and
you know play it out like if things were
moving fast at the time
we would bounce around and film
everything just constantly trying to get
stuff
so even with david i don't know his
story
i haven't been really talking to anybody
really lately
except for todd i asked him like what's
the deal with the situation because
i don't remember and you know i know
that i would never buy alcohol
well i believe you yeah but truly i
believe that
you are you are innocent and that you
didn't
you didn't create any of this situation
i believe that you
wouldn't i wouldn't come on here and
talk to you too because i know you guys
are masters at you know picking things
apart which is it
and you're trying to explain i don't i
don't think your presence is
evidence that you're innocent i mean
that's that's kind of a uh
if i had anything to hide i would not
come on i agree because i do think like
david doing a two-minute apology like i
even when you called me i was like wow
that's like because you're saying i was
trying to manipulate you i
don't think so because like you really
didn't have anything to apologize for me
for
but i do think like todd you say
yourself if people are silent they're
guilty todd and david just being silent
for so long until something so serious
comes along where you're all losing
brand deals
todd doesn't do [ __ ] so he's not losing
branches i'm not here to stick up for
anyone
they can speak up for themselves i don't
i don't think you're directly
guilty of anything but what i do suspect
is going on
is that you're withholding information
that would incriminate some of your
friends
i'm definitely not withholding
information i genuinely do not know
i don't know how the alcohol got there
but even seeing that passed out girl
like you don't like what's
like you just hung out there and you
guys were like oh this is cool like what
i don't i mean i
i left and to my understanding some of
the girls were 21
and you know like people can get a hold
of alcohol it's not that hard to get
it's not that strong but a girl being
blacked out especially a fan girl
like you wouldn't it's just like it
seems weird yeah but i had no part of it
i have no
part of that like so just to be clear
your story is changing now you left
after
you were saying 15 30 minutes and now
you're saying well i did come back at
the end of the night
clearly based on the photo
yeah yes the story's changed a little
bit so at what point in
the party did you peek into the bedroom
like i said i live
i live we live in apartment buildings i
live in an apartment in hollywood
and dom's apartment or x apartment where
i used to live i understand
yeah you guys are neighbors so what
point during the party did you
peek into the bedroom and pretend early
on
i mean so things happen fast
yeah because it sounds like in the video
he says we it wasn't happening
but after some time and convincing we
got him going
so it seems unlikely that in the first
30 minutes people would be in that
bedroom already
you know yeah when i peeked in the room
it was all
just pretending to try to act like we
were getting something so the girls
the girls pretended to go in there for
the vlog
the girls were in there but nobody was
kissing nobody was drinking and nobody
was
was it a setup though you see you're
implying that it was a setup
yeah i'm implying it's a setup i mean i
don't give a [ __ ] i've talked about this
before i've
said how david sets up a lot of his
bitsy i think he says it himself
it's like so the girls went on there and
pretended to hook up with dom you're
saying
because that's yeah because that's a
different account than what i've heard
from everybody else yeah to my
understanding yeah
that's that's how it happened and
they these girls they responded to you
know
instagram story that you know he was
asking who wanted who's going to come
have a five sum
or something with him something you know
crazy and then
they came over there and then i i don't
know if they wanted to film
i know their plan was to to be in the
vlog or film that
and again i don't want to take away from
the victim because
as i'm like explaining this story and
trying to like
voice my innocence i feel like i'm i'm
genuinely taken away from the scumbag
[ __ ] that dom did
and i mean that's why i'm here okay
i'm here i feel like so if i'm if i'm
believing your story that you left and
came back
i feel like you're trying to excuse
david a lot in your video as well
but the fact that there's almost no way
to excuse david if you believe the girls
right
you believe the girls you're explicitly
saying that so how is it that you can
say that david didn't do anything wrong
either
because he was there the whole time if
i'm to believe that you left and came
back
he knew that the girl pubed he knew that
the girl was black no i i i mean i can't
speak for anyone else but i i
to my understanding i think david left
too i think everybody left and then
and then they all came back and saw the
girl black it doesn't make any sense
just decided to post the vlog the next
day
everybody left and look look i did i'm
i'm telling you
everybody left and came back for a photo
at the end of the night
i'm sure dom and a few people stayed but
i think i have that this photos of you
guys at the end of the night
how is it i probably should have touched
up on on this with other people to get
the exact story straight but i you know
i just everybody what story straight the
truth or not
and that's dom's apartment yeah no like
actually what happened because
because here's everybody at the end of
the night 100
do not remember i mean i know if i saw
what they're saying the elevators at
dom's apartment do you feel bad about
the joke you made about like hey
they look good of course but why would
you i just understand why you would even
do that
like it's so incriminating like if you
knew that this would look bad why would
you even be a part of it
or i mean look we've all done we're all
humans you know we all make mistakes
you know i'm not sitting here like
bringing up your guys's stuff
that you've done yeah but i own up to it
like what i've said like
you're 100 innocent i'm owning up to it
yeah you're not you started your video
by saying i'm 100
innocent i'm innocent to the allegations
of i supplied them alcohol
that got them loosened up to be raped uh
i'm sorry you know whatever answer that
dan i know
it's live that's fine we're not here to
uh
mince mince words um
but you like continue to support dom
after this and you knew his vidcon stuff
you knew this stuff like
you knew that there was bad [ __ ] going
on when you saw that blacked out girl
and you still put them in your videos
like i just understand how it like
all the time bad stuff was going on and
i distanced myself from dom
i recently deleted the video and i'm
getting heat for that i mean i don't
understand that because that's like what
anybody would do that's what netflix
would do like
you know like i have no problem with you
erasing the dom videos that's what
i'm trying to avoid you know any
like online so do you understand how it
looks a little and sincere
like okay i understand you're defending
yourself saying you didn't supply the
alcohol and you didn't know this was
happening i believe that
but to come out and say you're 100
innocent that feels to me insincere to
those allegations i'm i i'm
guilty by association because i was
there and being a part of that
and and i'm fine with that like you can
you know i'm i'm here to tell the truth
but i think that's a big thing i am too
i've told her i said that too i'm guilty
by association for being
even the little bit i was there like
it's it's not it's not a good look and
like you should at least take i think
that's the thing all of you and you guys
all group each other and you say we
we no one takes accountability and you
guys think you do nothing wrong
i've said it i've i've said that like
i talked to you personally yeah offline
and
you know i told you that i stepped away
from dom a long time i haven't seen dom
in over a year
um even when i was texting why did you
step away from dom
just because i heard story i heard stuff
i don't know the exact stories
um
i did not know about the text i
genuinely did not know about that text
david knew about it
yeah i didn't know i mean i'm not up
david's ass like every you know like i'm
just i
i don't i have my own [ __ ] going on like
that's
something that i i doubt he wants to
tell everyone yeah
that is going on you know i i know that
he took the videos down and distanced
himself from dom too
and you know keep in mind we all play
exaggerated versions of ourselves it's
like i wouldn't say characters but like
everybody has their thing you know david
when he met me
he was uh he had found out i had been
arrested and that was like what he
um made my character kind of you know
and
whatever it is what it is like uh
i was okay with that um but dom's
character
was this dirtbag dirty dom and
you know i don't know how much is is
real and and
what's not you know i talked to dom off
camera and he didn't seem
like as intense as he was on camera like
when he gets into those like real
scumbag bits that he would do
and look to david who's a 21 year old
kid
he you know that was his friend that he
went to high school with i believe
and i guess he thought that was cool at
the time
you know i was never a fan of the sexual
bits i
i don't like them too much i don't think
they're funny i don't do them i make
videos too
i don't make jokes like that but um it
is what it is you know like we all
benefited from
david and his videos so it was uh
yeah it was like it was our
i mean do you have anything to say to um
you characterize the author
as uh as uh
you say she acts like she's doing the
lord's work
but she's really just trying to make
money do you feel like that's a fair
characterization
i'll be completely honest with you there
the focus here
it to me is on dom did a serious crime
he needs to go to jail
that is the focus of the article that
yeah the victim
it i i feel terrible for and i
in any way that i could help i would
love to but i
like in this situation i don't know what
to do um
do you feel unfair characterization to
characterize the author as a
as a liar who's just trying to make
money
i i think so i think what she did was
wrong by putting my name
in there with have you read the article
i have read the article afterwards yeah
bits and pieces yeah i
i mean i read the parts with my own name
in it
you have not read i can't speak for i
can't speak for other people so
you know like they they need to handle
that on their own so you haven't read
the whole article
is what you're saying no okay
because i feel that her characterization
of you is very
factual and straightforward and mild so
when you say to her you're a liar who's
just after the money
you're questioning in the entire
authentic you're questioning and the
validity of the entire article
and i've seen a lot of people taking
your video that way i look at it like
this
we're all you know this is all of our
jobs right what you're doing now is your
job what i'm doing now
is technically you know i'm i'm here
explaining myself
is this is this a criminal case or is
this a i don't
think no one's pressed charges or
anything yet
okay i don't know so everybody is now
i mean you have ads on these videos they
have ads on their videos
and their insider has a paywall
and there's a lot of money being made
off of this story where something
horrible happened and the guy who did it
is not in jail
and we're all just making content out of
it for entertainment now it seems like
and i'm the only one who did not
monetize my video
and and so mine's not monetized either
my david ones are never monetized the
stuff about you has never been monetized
i didn't know i didn't know that i
respect the fact that people are making
money has nothing to do with the
validity of the article we're all
working like you said
so i think she didn't put the entire
story together
based on what based on what you didn't
even read the interviews but mine and i
didn't even remember the situation
because
i i called immediately off impulse when
i saw my name attached to
something disgusting so i i called up
immediately and i
she said you denied being involved what
more do you want her to say
when two witnesses who were there say
that they saw you come in with alcohol
she said then she referred to a video of
trisha
that was not in the article for sure
referenced that was not in the article
it wasn't an article it was not in the
article it was in your conversation it
wasn't in the article because she
couldn't find the proof of it
the reference to the bar the the
barbershop conversation where
where that was oh no she did she that
was in our conversation but she didn't
put that and that's what my
problem was because i said to her yeah
that conversation she cut her clip
right off when i was about to say you
remember that recording you played
earlier
yeah at the end of it i said yeah todd
likes whiskey so i made fun of them in a
barber shop this is where she cut
no you're wrong dude you said in the
clip that i was playing
you said that he does drink whiskey i
said
he does drink whiskey and that's where
she cut and right after that i said but
that was in a barbershop episode
that was filmed two years after this
situation but the way you say
i don't think that that delegitimizes
everything
she said you said she said is it
possible todd
brought alcohol you said i don't think
so but he does like whiskey
yeah because there was whiskey there so
how is she mischaracterizing you
because the way she worded it it implied
that i was
covering my own ass but saying that todd
did kind of buy it but i want to protect
myself
which is not true so why did but okay
we're arguing semantics dude that's not
enough to do
because overall people even the stuff in
your video people weren't accusing you
of doing anything other than like
i heard that you went to go get i'll
call the girl said you guys brought back
a whole that was it that was the extent
of your accusations no one said that you
did anything wrong with the girls or
anything which is why
i was like surprised people told me that
trisha told me
that you and todd in a barber shop
episode that was internet yeah
that's the only reason i even referenced
it in the article well
does todd like whiskey via toddler
okay so there you go and you said it to
her and she put in the [ __ ] article
but the way she was so how are you gonna
justify putting her name out there
and it's calling her like some liar
who's just money hungry that's just
that's just a dishonest that's just not
a fair characterization well
well the story here is to me the problem
is dom he's the one who did the
essay here and and david
i think david yes
very much also david alcohol i
understand david had no recollection of
this
except the tag come on he filmed it he
was there with the limped out girl he
went back to get the closure of the
thing he got the text message a year and
a half ago
i thought he faked the shot the next day
of that yes and
so when did this happen when did the
assault happen the girl you're in a
photo of the girl after she was
assaulted being held up by her friend
drunk dude
all you guys are there and you also
posted it i mean
if you really didn't know and you see a
girl like that maybe don't include her
in the vlog her face wasn't blurred in
the original vlog
i don't control that stuff okay but
david does
yeah david literally controls that look
i'm not trying to make you incriminate
your friend or anything i'm just saying
i think the way you're not the guy
that's gonna speak up for david okay
fine
but don't defend him you just credit me
you you know you say oh it wasn't david
it's just from
you i apologize i apologize for
discrediting you but look in all
fairness
in all fairness trisha like we've we've
met a few times
in real life and i mean the first time
we met you flashed me you know like at
this
like one of the time maybe the third or
fourth time i went to go see you
i didn't go see you i was in the car
with david and jason when they drove to
visit you in the hospital
i don't know if you're comfortable
talking about this but which i just
don't know why you were there for that i
don't know why david was there for that
i
wanted to rush to see you and i was with
him we were out vlogging and trying to
get content
and they rushed there to get their
flashing was consensual don't make it
seem like i just exposed myself to you
guys
i'm like he's like do you guys want to
see church's boobs don't act like i was
just like
ugh you know here's like my boobs that
wasn't they asked you
we asked permission it wasn't like i
just did that huh
and maybe david asked you guys they
asked you guys i wasn't gonna just
anyways i would never ask to see jason's
girlfriend's boobs no you didn't ask to
see them he said can trisha flash you
and you guys were like yeah no trisha i
would not i would never
i i i remember in the video i was like
please
you're not just like you're not it's
about that you're my friend's girlfriend
right
right um and then like yeah the time at
the hospital is
it's it's a serious thing you you're at
a low place and you look much better now
but i didn't go in there and see you
even but i'm just saying from those
times
i stayed out in the lobby and i
i you know i just tagged along because
they wanted to rush there but why
discredit me in these what because i
flashed you because i was in a hospital
now i'm not a credible source but i
didn't
because the um
i mean you were declared 51.50 that
night correct
because i overdosed you get 51.50 if
you're attempted suicide
yeah it's not because i'm crazy as i try
to kill myself
so then when you started making videos
and stuff
about jason i only heard jason's side of
the story where he tried to avoid
any uh contact with you at all because
you were s suicidal and he
we [ __ ] for four months after i was at
coachella you were no i was at the house
in coachella how do you think i got down
there
i don't i i didn't know this showed up
i heard you showed up at the house and
you just popped up
i can't control what everybody like this
is just what i hear you're discrediting
me
by witnessing this because i try to kill
myself you're like well christian i
killed
so don't listen to what she has to say
no i'm i'm apologizing for that i'm
apologizing for discrediting you i'm
just explaining why at first i did
discredit you
because after that then the starbucks
situation happened
and at that time i didn't know i i know
you guys had a nasty breakup you drove
your car into his house and stuff like
that so i just didn't want to be
involved
and i saw you and i i i left
because i didn't want to have an
interaction with you at all
because of all the stuff that had
happened afterwards
and you know i
i that's just me being but do you think
that's why i i
corroborated the story when i got
reached out to for comment you think i'm
doing this as like a vendetta
at the time i i did yeah i thought that
but take me out of the article this
these two girls still said you were the
one who played the alcohol so if i never
gave a comment it would still have the
same story that you supply the alcohol
without me involved
but your only line of defense is to
attack me
well it was because the article had a
story
from you saying that it was a barbershop
episode that not in the article it
wasn't in the article
well that's what cat said and it's not
an
article dude you think you'd think you
would read the article
you also before making a whole video
anyway listen we're talking in circles a
little bit i just want to get
finally on the record you have you don't
apologize to cat for what you said about
her in your video
i want to know what what cat's objective
is
is it to get the girl's story out yes
because you were such a small part of it
you were literally two lines of the
whole article
so the fact that you made this video
blew my mind you know you when you
apologize like oh that makes sense you
know
you were involved in some capacity as
was i so you're scared as you know as
anybody would be and then you made this
video attacking me and cat and i was
like
but that's not the issue of of i'm
always skeptical of
these articles that come out with
clickbait titles
they charge money for and again i don't
want to discredit the victim here
but but it's like there is money coming
from this
where is this money going everything
what are we good what are we doing to
help i know
so am i like to believe that nothing in
the new york times is credible because
they charge money for the newspaper
i'm sorry say that again am i should i
believe that nothing in the new york
times is credible because they charge
money for the newspaper
well i look at it like this if you
are speaking on a case of a sexual
assault and your goal is to get
the story out there for the victim to
get her story out
and you link it to a celebrity and it
makes a lot of money
i think you should use that money and
give it back
to sexual assault that's up to the
insider they can't
but you do that's a ridiculous case you
can't as a functioning journalistic
newspaper they can't set up it's not an
escrow account and start donating
to the victims of every article they
cover it's just it's a
i thought i felt guilty for being a part
of this
and i went and donated to a sexual
assault champion i'm happy i did that
and i'm just trying to why can't you
just say that and let it be why do you
have to like attack me and cat because
that goes a long way if you're like this
is something disgusting i was a part of
more than todd has said more than david
has said david didn't even acknowledge
her in the apology
you know you've done more by donating by
talking about it by you know making a
video about it and if you don't that's
what i wanted to come on here to do
and i thought that we could talk this
out and and we could find a way to use
our platforms to help
um and in any way if it's just
like when i tried you caught right
before i shared the article about
insider and
how i actually feel about this i've
talked with actual
sexual uh sa
victims and you know i i didn't
spend time reading this specific article
but i did my research
and i feel like i'm trying to learn here
in this situation
my guilt is only by association in that
in that bit just by
going listen again i think i think
you're from what i can tell a good dude
i don't think you ness you you're i
understand that you feel bad and i
believe
that like you didn't have anything to do
with the events that as they unfolded
i think the intent of the author was to
first of all talk about dom
first of all talk about david how he
enabled it and the culture of the entire
vlog squad which unfortunately you are a
member of
how it all acts to enable this kind of
thing which i don't know if you've been
following
but there's more and more videos of
girls saying similar stuff happened to
them like this
through the ball squad now nobody's
directly saying you did
everybody understand what i'm just
saying that like
this is now going down but like i i'm
you know for me morally i feel like i'm
i'm completely
innocent and now this whole thing is
crashing down
and i understand it's because my name
was put in this by this reporter so
that's why maybe
but the vlog itself your association
even if it was a joke and you guys were
faking it like you should have
sponsorships taken away for you like
peeking in on someone having sex that's
not consenting even if it was a joke it
doesn't look like a joke
i didn't i did not peek in on them
having sex or faking it you faked it i
faked peeking in what's the difference
to the viewer
i mean why did why have you guys done
the things that you have done
we make mistakes you know i'm not going
to get into that detail i'm happy with
you owning the mistakes i just don't
understand
why listen i i hear you
i feel i'm sorry for all the things
you're going through and everything
i hope that that you know you can just
push forward and everything's gonna be
okay with you i think that
you don't deserve to be canceled and i
hope that you can just keep doing your
show
and i know your fans are gonna keep
supporting you and i hope that you know
in time you can get through this and
stay strong
and this doesn't destroy your career i
don't think that it will that being said
right before and before i end i just
took a minute to think about
the situation with this reporter yeah i
understand she doesn't run inside her
um i
apologize for putting her like i threw
that video together quick
and i just felt like i needed like i was
being accused of these things i had my
mom texted me
she was worried that my name was linked
in this stuff and
um i was just like you know it was
impulsive to put out a video like that
so quick so there were things that
weren't perfect in it and you just
chewed it apart but
i don't even think we got to the part
where oh yeah you did
i i i apologize for putting her name her
twitter up
because i wanted to send people to
attack her
that was wrong and that came off wrong
and i apologize for that
but as far as the wording of the story
i would have appreciated it if it was a
little bit better but you know
it is what it is i guess that's why you
just don't talk to reporters and that's
why nobody's speaking but me
but i felt that if i came on here and
just genuinely talked from the heart
that i would be able to show that i am
a good person i had nothing to do with a
sexual assault
i had nothing to do with with anything
that happened inside of that bedroom
when i peeked in it was a faked bit and
the sweaty part after was a
fake a setup shot after the next day and
i mean that's my story that's from three
years ago that's what i remember
and i i can i can well you know i think
from what i can tell i agree i think
you're a good dude and like i said i
hope you get through this and you're
okay
but
uh what is the goal here because for me
it's to
try to help sexual assault victims
genuinely i that's genuinely what i'm
i'm here for
and you know well
what you're doing when you question the
motives of the authors you're basically
saying
that there's no article that could be
about this that would be acceptable to
me
because they're making money and if
there was a paywall on it and you wanted
to get those clicks through doing it
this way
they had lawyers david's lawyers were
threatening them non-stop they have i
don't know i i don't know this stuff
well you act like i'm with david every
day well it's in the article if you
would have [ __ ] read the article
okay ethan um i just think i was just
like more of like
i just felt like really bad that you
were discrediting me because it wasn't
even about me i just think i can't like
i don't know why
so many times for discrediting you i'm
sorry for saying that you're crazy i
know i know and i appreciate that i
think i think honestly just taking it
because like you said you said i i'm
guilty by association and that is a huge
thing
i've been guilty by association many
times i think that's just a big thing i
think closure i think just
like people just admitting they did
something wrong is a big thing and then
yeah of course you saying that the end
of the video is way more than anybody
else has done david taught anybody
so i i'm i'm all for you i told i told
ethan when he checked you know
uh sent me the thing so it just caught
me off guard this morning i also told
trish video that's
would you guys mind pulling up the video
and we could go through that
which video the actual vlog the deleted
vlog
sure [ __ ] it would you mind because i
don't mind
we're here i feel like we've given we
might
so i might as well just let you [ __ ]
i appreciate you saying something i
appreciate you calling me someone just
like me that video or highlighter
this would be a cringe fest because i'm
embarrassed of of how i look in this i i
saw it you know cut together in
many videos i've been watching
especially your guys's
jeff if i could just talk to you before
you made that video i would have told
you
just say i'm sorry i regret being there
what happened was horrible the fact that
my name's even associated with something
so terrible it's just
it's humiliating and awful i'm donating
to this
i'm removing all the videos with dom i
made a horrible mistake
being involved in this even a little bit
i didn't get the alcohol but you know
what
there's confusion the witnesses
something that you continue to ignore
say that you return with the alcohol
maybe they're wrong maybe they're not
remembering it right jeff and that's
fine
but they say it so you keep passing the
buck oh is the reporter oh it's tricia
that was the witnesses that were there
said you came with it
now let's say maybe they're wrong maybe
todd got it maybe you came in and todd
got it whatever
but there's just that's it that's all
there is to it
i hate to discredit anyone here in this
situation even the friends
but knowing that i didn't get that
alcohol
it's like how can i even you can't
listen to that you can't
i can't discredit anyone because it's
literally just you can go through your
bank statements from three years ago or
go to the amp
i said i said i i said what do you want
me to do i go through my bank statements
there's no way that i can prove that i
didn't get the alcohol
exactly tell you that i didn't buy
alcohol and three i got sober
a friend that passed away and around the
time i was drinking
heavily and i quit drinking completely
and i i used to have a podcast with
scott and i would talk about
how i don't support you know like i i
try to help people out with alcohol
problems and stuff like that
you know but i mean that's that's
regardless from this point because there
are people drinking
in the place and yeah you also told me
you distanced yourself from like david
and them you're not really like in the
vlog squad anymore
well i've been i i wasn't in a bad
accident so i've been recovering
was that in utah and stuff like that
your eye was in utah
yeah i don't i don't really want to get
into it but it was a david bit right it
was for a vlog
i don't know i don't want to get into
that okay okay
i've got the video how do i share this
with jeff so he can watch in real time
what is it it's the video that you
wanted to watch
okay it's of the part the footage of the
bottom of the party yeah can you see it
i can't see it's this one
yeah okay and then it's this one
okay can you see out of your eye jeff
oh he's gone yeah no he's here so you're
fine you're not you're not
blind i'm not trying to be insensitive
but you're not you can see
i don't want to talk about health stuff
really this is about the victim and not
about me and my own personal life jeff
can you see the video
yeah okay i'm gonna go ahead and play it
these girls over to have a five some so
hopefully i have a fivesome
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is tonight the girls walked in and
they were like is this the guy we're
having the seventh one
i have to let you guys i don't really
know any of you i mean immediately i was
i mean i know i'm not being the one
accused here but
immediately even there you see it i'm
not really this is not
a bit i want nobody's well sure nobody's
saying that
right if you just you know get the [ __ ]
out of here
you guys are the only ones for me i
don't talk to any other girl
after a couple minutes of talking we've
blurred the girls by the way if anyone's
wondering
yeah the girls are i thought my eye
actually was really bad no they're
blurred out
it was clear there was no fivesome
happening tonight he called it
yeah i mean look for here
even here like trisha i'm sure you you
you understand this we drive around
desperately
looking for bits and like here
the emotion in our faces is like okay
let's get the [ __ ] out of here this is
dumb
you know yeah but um
again this is this is all refreshing my
memory
because um i came on here
to just talk to you guys about it all
and just be honest
so i mean yeah i guess you keep rolling
so you left that
but by some stroke of luck and master
negotiating dom made progress
what do you think david meant by master
negotiating
what do i think he meant by that i mean
it's pretty it's
pretty clear i guess he's trying to sum
up a story in his vlog with voice over
short and everything how do you convince
someone to have sex with you in the
matter of uh
the course of the evening the girls i
mean i
i don't want to discredit anyone but
they answered a dm
that was uh uh you know basically an ad
for yeah but that doesn't do that
doesn't mean that they consent to uh
yeah i agree i i i even i take that back
yeah i mean the fact that they answered
that doesn't mean anything more than
they just wanted to hang out with some
celebrities
so what do you think it means that he
negotiated his way to sleep with them
oh this part was this part right here
was staged that we were walking into the
room
um and then i was over there looking
into the room this was
stage same day or different day this was
the day we were there
you and i okay i'll keep playing it
but there is alcohol sometime has passed
you guys
david and the girls were there for two
hours old or something like that i mean
he could have alcohol in his house
you know it's it dom lived there so i
you know it's not like but drinking was
happening
i don't know why we're watching this i
feel like it's kind of pointless to be
honest
okay we don't have to it's fine i don't
i mean at this part it's great well
unless you have something new that do
you have something new to add is there
some specific
i just wanted to get i wanted to get
through this and get through the whole
story and just you know
maybe i could i can refresh my memory
and stuff i'll go ahead it's not that
much longer yeah
[Music]
you know that's you want to finish the
video you want to wrap it up
i'd say we [ __ ] wrap it up okay
because it's you know
disturbing and i'm sure it's triggering
so i listen once again i want to
reiterate
i don't wish ill for you i really don't
i think i think you're going to get
through this fine i know it feels bad
and it's traumatic
i feel like you did trisha and cat dirty
and that's
that's basically it and i feel like
you're covering for your boys that's
about it
i mean i can i can only speak for myself
you know they have to cover for
themselves
yeah i think trisha made the best point
too it's like
you're misplacing your anger i feel like
you know what i mean
the person who put you in this kind of
situation was
not trisha or the victims or the
reporter
i cho i mean i chose to roll roll along
and
you know and be in the vlog i wanted to
get more
jokes done more videos done it's our
jobs
um but yeah that that wasn't the plan at
all
for how that went down of course i
understand that and i think that's like
somewhat of a success people think i'm
just trying to bring you all down it's
like i just would like
i know as someone who's gone through
some [ __ ] myself as anybody has like
closure's a big thing taking
accountability and saying like hey i
[ __ ] up i'm sorry
including david jason whatever and this
is such a minor thing like you just
saying it like i [ __ ] up like that's a
to me that's a big thing because nobody
in your group that's why i'm surprised
you're even doing this
what like when you were supposed to be
on paul said i know everyone's like you
can't go on a pulse like everyone
in that group i know how it is because
when josh went on and he got ripped
apart so the fact that you're on here is
like
somewhat impulsive recently you did go
on impulsive recently
what i mean i'm gonna open up and i'm
gonna i'm gonna like
be clear on what's going on in my life
i've i've been in a dark spot for a
while now
and you know i didn't plan on coming out
and doing any of this
i i this set's halfway done i you know i
i wanted to wait for the right moment
but um
these allegations and once i saw that
email i just impulsively
just called that reporter right away and
i should have done research
i should have you know read more i
should have read more of the article i
only cared about myself
to clear my own name so i i apologize
for that but
you know i like it's
it's like an umbrella of the vlog squad
that if david
does something wrong then everybody goes
down
you know and this is one person who's in
the in the squad now that's done
something horribly disgusting
and he dragged all of us down too
because yeah of course it's shocking
when you get a phone call with somebody
partnered with for years and you had a
great relationship and
now they're they're asking you that they
want to end their partnership
because of something so disgusting that
somebody else did that
i had no idea about i genuinely had no
idea about until i got the email
and then i started asking around and
then you know i i
found out what really happened and it's
it's just been a rough
couple days still getting my thoughts
together i understand
yeah i listen i totally get it i
i i'm i wish you well i really genuinely
do
i mean jeff is the most successful
without david so that's why i was again
was kind of surprised because you've
kind of always been your own entity so i
was kind of like
oh to me again i still feel like you're
covered like you're hiding some things
but
not just to cover your guys not anything
else that'd be you now trisha
huh and you'd be the most successful
without david now
oh well thank you i'll take it i mean i
definitely crashed after but i think
by like again i i just appreciate you
you know we all make mistakes yeah and
look
you've done some you've made some
mistakes but look you're doing good now
i mean a lot of those things i've made
tons of mistakes and i always own up to
it obviously going to jason's house high
on meth i've owned up to i don't
try and sugarcoat it in any way it's my
bad and it just is a thing
yeah but you can made a bunch of
mistakes
hey hey hey daniel hey dance we're not
here to talk about that
talking [ __ ] before dan dan there's some
places in that tick tock boxing match i
heard you're tick tock all right
oh my god wait what's that saying about
dan you're going to box down
i'll make sure i'm issuing uh a boxing
challenge uh
no i am not a dick talker you uh you
seem to be confused
i didn't do my research maybe dan you
have a tick tock
no no comments his hair is his blonde
hair
i thought he was a dick cocker because
he has a hair
i wish you well i appreciate that you
are willing to come
call in and subject yourself to this
abuse
i feel like at this point this should
have been a criminal case and it should
be investigated by
well it might be it's a fresh story i
think a lot of times girls are scared
most people are scared so i don't come
out with it up until recently when like
big nick seth i think other people are
coming out now because they're not as
scared as david's power which he had a
lot of power
people saw what happened to me when i
left you know everyone thought i was
crazy and i was you know
tossed aside or whatever so people were
scared but i think more people come out
now because you know yeah but that's not
always the case
and i can speak for that like the group
sometimes people choose to leave
and sometimes people are they
they genuinely do something wrong and
i've seen
some people that have you know done
something wrong and taken advantage of
david's
name and want to accuse him of stuff out
you think that's me i'm not saying
david's perfect no i'm not saying that
to you you're fine on your own you and
ethan got a great thrill here
i was like i didn't do that yeah um but
like for instance i mean i don't want to
spill the beans on too many people but
uh also i can't just make an accusation
and not back it up
um [ __ ] it should i say it here do you
guys want dirt or do you want it yeah
yes us please it was something [ __ ] i
mean it's such a
such a uh i mean it's a guy i don't want
to have beef with
who is that i shouldn't say it
go ahead go ahead no it's not brandon
go ahead i can't think of any others
zayn
no go ahead jeff um i'll
wrestle zane jeff
what is it uh no like i've seen you have
people on the show here and
not to discredit the other situation
with the essay
but um i know big nick came on here and
i mean like again i don't i don't want
to have [ __ ] problems with big nick
but um yeah he was uh
he was caught doing some
sketchy stuff and i'll just tell you the
story we had like an easter egg hunt
vlog
on uh you see now i feel like a rat
and i came on here to to do something
different but
uh yeah [ __ ] it i don't even want to
tell a story
because it's like yeah it's not even
you want to complete the thought because
it might be
misconstrued i don't want to throw
people under the bus i i came on here to
just voice my concerns for the victim
and
and say my innocence so i think i think
i think we've said all that that we need
to here today so
yeah i don't know i wish you well i
think you're gonna be fine you're gonna
make you're gonna get through this just
you know
do your thing and uh i think you'll be
all right
and your eye story tell it because i
think there's a lot of speculation on it
i read the blog
so i know everybody has something to say
they think i'm blind and they get a
glass eye and you know
um it's just it's stuff that like i'm
wearing glasses
because you know like i i haven't been
filming
videos because i'm a little insecure
about it so i just been laying low
and um i had some surgery done on it so
that's why i like
when i was dealing with this reporter
and stuff um
on pain meds and like my eyes stitch
shut
and i'm emotional and you know that's
why i just call
when everybody's like don't call just
you know well i understand the
listen you have nothing to hide cl or i
mean supposedly
i would consider apologizing to kat i
think you did her dirty but that's but
that
i think that's about the only thing i
want to say about it i apologize for
putting her name in and saying like look
this is her twitter
i apologize to you for that cat that
that you didn't deserve you don't
deserve to get a bunch of hate
but um there were some things in the
article that i just can't you know
i i can't apologize to her because she
still put in
knowing that they were not all right
well i do suggest reading it and then
maybe you'll change your mind
i read the part apology all right thank
you for calling in jeff take care all
right
thanks guys nice all right meeting you
bye
so he didn't read the article our hunch
was right
right probably a lot could have been
avoided if you read the article
but i feel bad i do feel bad for him
because i feel like he
will you know i do i feel bad on him
i feel bad on a human level for him
right now
because i know what he's going through
but before he makes this epic
my truth statement he gotta [ __ ] get
his [ __ ] straight
i think he he's obviously the emotional
one of the group because even on the
scott cast like he's always like come
for me like he's the one that's like a
little fiery in the group so i think he
just got like a little bit
heated in the moment but um his dude and
dude i didn't say but you've got to take
those videos down to the sponsor asked
or
cut it out you got to figure that out
bro trust me you just just you can't
you don't want that so he did he does he
does apologize for discrediting me he
doesn't yeah he apologized to you
he gave cat a half apology i'll take it
yeah you got a full-on yeah that was
good i guess i was like what
what is me having going on but at the
same time what does that mean for his
video that's still up for his channel
where he's basically saying trisha
caught you know what i mean like
i think i hope so because it's not
accurate it's not accurate um
if i was jeff i would reshoot a better
apology
and put it out there right i do think
he's going through some [ __ ] hey you
know it's i think
i'll say this allegedly allegedly
allegedly um is it from a david bit
that's why i wanted him to talk about it
because some [ __ ] went down in utah
that's why he didn't talk about it but i
read these blogs these like
vlog squad blogs to keep up with it this
was
yeah or 2020 or something and they all
went on this trip and nothing was ever
posted from it and then all of a sudden
jeff has like this like eye out and it
was
bad and he's like i don't want to talk
about him with david i want to talk
about
which is again he ever right now to talk
about it but i think if he spilled the
beans on that that's his story
he goes on impulsively those beans you
should spill them here in front of me
what was he going on about big nick
i don't know i was like dude whoa
wrong one i mean big nick just said that
he felt bullied i mean what do you got
what did what are we going after big
nick for now yeah just cause he
i mean not saying he we don't vouch for
him you want mexican food
[Music]
yeah that's sad he said it was the most
successful
thank you also was successful before
david i had shane before david also i
i get the feeling that jeff is kind of
charming and funny so i was like
stop the [ __ ] i know i like it
though i was kind of like oh yeah this
is why people like you
yeah but like let's see for flashing him
excuse me that was a bit that david
asked to do show your boobs
i don't want him trying to win over the
audience for being charming when like
you know what i don't think he went over
the audience with that
well in the beginning but again i do
think that this picture
tells a lot and i believe that he
doesn't remember
i don't believe he went away and came
back i mean that seems kind of funny and
david too they all went away and came
back
all left at this perfect
definitely covering some stuff but
um all right i mean that's it that's all
i have to say about that in the words of
forrest gump
well his sponsors will come back he has
enough creativity on his own
it'll take time thank you for giving me
a third wave i feel like i've gone
through
shane gave me the first wave then david
then oh we're not falling out
well we almost did but we pulled through
you're married you mean you're marrying
my brother-in-law so it's like we're
stuck
kind of removing the options you have an
after cat
i'm not the kind of dude who like holds
grudges i like to settle squash beef
especially with people like in my family
which you are you're also like the most
like human person
why'd you do it like that what do you
mean human
um you aren't really like just like
you know what it is is you always like
defend me like when i was in hot [ __ ]
like hot water from this immigration
david i don't know i guess it's not as
shitty as the other people who are just
like bye
shane's like never defended me he never
came to my live shows david threw me
into the bus
like so you're like the least awful
thank you
but i've done awful stuff to you that's
fine i don't care
i've done awful stuff to you and you've
like given me a second third chance i
know i know what it is
what what is it look i understand you as
a person and
the ebbs and flows of the personality of
trish and i take it all for what it is
well i'm not in therapy now maybe it
makes a difference or not something like
old
hmm let's order some mexican food
are you serious yeah is it good though i
don't know
i'll just pick some place on postman
once i know he says no to your mexican
food
oh you don't want no he thinks that
you're oh okay
i'm not cooking it well clearly we're
the better cook in this situation is me
so we will not be eating your cookies
don't you dare say it bring that [ __ ] up
now
got him all right let's wrap this up how
long okay
listen we've said it all going
i just i don't know what to say about
jeff like i feel bad for him but it's
also like
dude so many inconsistencies also by me
and the bees lemonade it supports the
bees everything goes to the bees 100
yeah i'm working hard to help bees we
love the bees
shout out to the bees folks it's not
sponsored but all of this 100 profit
goes to bees we love that
frenemies merch coming soon all right
guys stop the asian hate
report as a hate crime
bye is that it
[Music]
[Music]
you